the White House does not deal with the
sin problem our Medical Offices do not
deal with the sin problem the Marchers
and the protesters they don't deal with
the sin problem they are dealing with
the symptoms but they're not dealing
with the sin and so what we're going to
do tonight is we're going to investigate
how do we address this problem now to
add insult to
injury I want to take us to another
Bible passage and then we're going to
draw our attention to the screen screen
go to Isaiah 59 I want you to watch what
the Bible says because I want to
introduce you to one more problem that
as a result of this series The Gospel
the sanctuary and Bible prophecy through
this series we're going to learn about
another problem that can be solved and I
want you to watch this it's in Isaiah
the 59th chapter that the Bible says
something that's very important for us
to consider and here's what it says in
Isaiah we're looking at chapter 59 and
we're going to consider verse 2 it says
in Isaiah 59 and:
2 but your
iniquities have separated between you
and your God and then it says and your
sins in my sins have hid his face from
you that he will not hear Once Upon a
Time Mankind and God had face-to-face
communion it was
beautiful and then sin came into the
picture
and When sin came into the picture it
caused God for the first time to turn
his face from
Mankind and this is why God can no
longer talk face to face to Mankind and
he speaks to Mankind through symbols and
mediums and all these other things but
God wants to remove all those things and
talk face to face with his people once
again but did you know that even God has
a
problem that almost sounds Blasphemous
doesn't it but I promise you it's not
but even God has a problem you know what
his problem
is how does he destroy the
sin but Save The
Sinner that's a very serious problem and
did you know he's going to give you and
I of which we're going to discover this
week or these two weeks together he's
going to give you and I an understanding
of how to solve that problem we actually
can play a part in helping solve God's
problem
how to destroy the sin but yet Save The
Sinner and the only way he can do that
is a reverse of what we just read sin
came in and separated us from God so you
know what God's going to do God's going
to come in our hearts and he's going to
separate us from our sins wow
wow did you just did you get the
Goosebumps like I did on that one that
was good that that was an immediate
download high five to the Lord for that
one that was good
it was our sins that separated us from
God God says that's all right I'm going
to come in your heart and I'm going
separate your sins from you and all
throughout our studies together the
gospel the sanctuary and Bible prophecy
we're going to see how God is going to
solve his problem and by default solve
the sin
problem well greetings thank you for
being here so God has a very serious
problem SDA evangelist Dwayne lemon
tells us and his problem is how does he
destroy sin but Save The
Sinner and if you weren't
aware to solve this
problem the scriptures allegedly teach
that you can play a part in helping God
solve his big
problem as you can imagine when I first
heard this I was not shocked in
Adventist theology the Adventist God
family has all sorts of problems they
are struggling to actualize because of
how limited and creature-like they are
but it reminded me of how the great
controversy theme is as per usual in the
driver's seat when it comes to the way
that Adventist teachers like this read
and teach the Bible which provides us
with a perfect opportunity to showcase
how this is absolutely the case and cut
through the theological fog to help
people see how this system of the ology
is a crafty deception we are going to be
breaking the ice on a number of topics
tonight that I've talked about in
passing before but did not camp out on
namely Union with Christ glorification
and the distinction between Redemption
accomplished and Redemption
applied and the subject of sin is the
perfect context to unpack such and show
how Adventist theology is neither
biblical nor Apostolic if you are new
here welcome my name is Miles and
answering adventism is an apologetic
effort aimed at the Christian church to
raise the general awareness of the body
of Christ on the theological deceptions
and dangers of Seventh Adventist
theology it is fundamental friend
fundamental Christian
friend that you as a Christian
understand that the Seventh Adventist
Church has its own unique worldview
which I refer to a lot around here as a
product because the SDA church is a
business and they are absolutely selling
a product and that product is the great
controversy theme and individuals like
Dwayne lemon whether knowingly or
unknowingly they are purveyors of that
product they are the equivalent of a
Salesman for the SDA organization
pedaling the product showcasing it in an
attempt to get people to buy into it now
along the way the Bible is
supplementally uh utilized but really
it's the Great controversy theme that
you are being sold the great controversy
theme is a worldview that includes a
pre-earth origin narrative entailing all
sorts of information not found in the
Bible it comes from the writings of
Ellen G white which borrow names titles
and Concepts from the
Bible to tell an origin story of what
was allegedly going on in heaven prior
to the existence of the earth and
Humanity think of it like a prior to
Genesis set of information
this information is then brought to the
Bible and it informs how the SDA Church
understands and
interprets the Bible and the problem of
sin is no
exception when Dwayne lemon speaks of
the sin problem being resolved and sin
being
removed he is speaking about how the
Adventist God is allegedly on trial due
to accusations made by Satan about God
and His
law
namely the charge that God's law is not
fair it cannot be kept it needs to be
changed
Etc again this accusation allegedly
began in heaven before the Earth even
existed as can be seen in Ellen White's
Patriarchs and Prophets like you see on
screen where she writes
quote from the first the great
controversy had been upon the law of God
Satan had sought to prove that God was
unjust that his law was faulty that the
good of the universe required it to be
changed in attacking the law he aimed to
overthrow the authority of its
author in the controversy it was to be
shown whether the Divine statutes were
defective and subject to change or
perfect and
immutable close
quote this is to say that the central
focus in this alleged controversy is
over the law of God the Ten Commandments
God's government his character all terms
that adven theology uses interchangeably
to refer to the law but this is to say
that in Orthodox SDA
theology God and his character are on
trial because of these accusations from
Satan and God must now vindicate himself
from these
accusations so when Dwayne lemon says
God has a problem a big problem and you
and I can help him fix it this is the
root of what he is getting at God being
both the just and the justifier a phrase
found in Romans 3 that phrase is
informed in light of this pre-earth
storyline because by God being just SDA
a theology proper understands that to be
referring to God's law being Vindicated
from these accusations of Satan
something these scriptures do not teach
or claim
now within this storyline they also
claim that when these accusations began
God had to hold a council meeting to
figure out a
solution and part of that included
brainstorming over how the problem of
Satan and sin was going to be
solved Satan had planted seeds of Doubt
amongst the angels and if God would have
just obliterated Satan immediately upon
Him
sinning that would have reinforced his
charges against God being a tyrant Etc
so to solve the problem he decided he
would let sin run its course and let
creatures see the disastrous results
that would come with it you heard Dwayne
say the gospel the sanctuary and Bible
prophecy well the sanctuary is a seven
step model that was supposedly
foreshadowed in the Old Testament
priesthood work it supposedly
foreshadowed seven steps that Jesus
would carry out through the sanctuary to
remedy the sin problem that's what he's
getting at by saying God is going to
solve his is problem and by default
solve the sin problem but in order for
God to be Vindicated of these charges
meaning to ultimately solve the problem
Dwayne lemon tells us that we also play
a part in that solution we help God in
some form or fashion to vindicate
himself and his law from Satan
so what is that
role we see one of many statements about
this in Ellen White's inhe Heavenly
place places she writes quote so deep
was the Lord's interest in the beings
that he had created so great his love
for the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life John 3:16 Christ came
to bring moral power to man to elevate
inoble and strengthen him enabling him
to be a partaker of the divine nature
having escaped the corruption that is in
the world through
lust he proved to the inhabitants of the
unfallen worlds and to human beings that
the law can be
kept while possessing the nature of man
he obeyed the law of God vindicating
God's justice in demanding that it be
obeyed in the Judgment his life will be
an unanswerable argument in favor of
God's law close
quote so the role that Humanity plays in
helping God solve this big problem is
keeping the law perfectly demonstrating
to all watching intelligences in the
universe because they believe there's
beings on all these other worlds they're
all watching and on the earth like a
stage like a movie
screen and it's to prove to all the
watching intelligences of the universe
that the law of God can be kept not only
this but it's what the great controversy
storyline claims is the reason for why
Jesus came this is an area of serious
difference between SDA Theology and
Christian theology regardless of your
stripe or tradition that's not what we
believe about why Jesus came into our
world but nevertheless yes in this
framework Jesus came to demonstrate to
humans that they can keep the law he did
it and you can come to him by faith and
do just like he did and also vindicate
God's law before all the watching
intelligences of the universe Angels
other Humans Beings on these other
worlds that are all supposedly watching
in on the earth
Etc this is to say that according to
this
worldview according to the world viiew
friend not every individual Seventh Day
Adventist out there most of them are not
even learn it on what they're part
of according to this worldview achieving
total sinlessness in this life is the
role that you play in helping God solve
his serious problem to use Dwayne's
words so keep that in mind as we are
listening tonight and see if you notice
how that the underlaying
foundation that that's the underlying
foundation and that's what the teach is
ultimately built upon that's what's in
the backdrop and being brought to the
text to then cite the Bible and make it
sound like what's being taught is coming
from the
Bible now Dwayne lemon is going to be
teaching pelagian heresy which is
ancient it just serves a unique purpose
within the Adventist context because of
the unique great controversy Paradigm
that it is nestled within but like I
said this topic gives us a perfect
opportunity not only to examine how
Adventist theology contradicts the Bible
but but also discuss why the distinction
between Redemption accomplished and
Redemption
applied is
important I'm going to be saying this a
lot tonight Redemption accomplished
versus Redemption
applied two aspects of redemption that
if one does not understand well you'll
make blunders like we're going to see
Dwayne lemon make regarding scripture
and what it is teaching but speaking of
the scriptures
I want to remind everyone of something
else that the SDA Prophet has said in
Patriarchs and Prophets and it will be
pertinent to uh remember tonight as we
listen this is her commenting on the
fall of Adam and Eve she writes quote
notwithstanding the sophistry of Satan
to the contrary it's always disastrous
to disobey
God we must set our hearts to know what
is truth all the lessons which God has
caused to be placed on record in his
word are for hour warning and
instruction they are given to save us
from deception their neglect will result
in ruin to
ourselves whatever contradicts God's
word we may be sure proceeds from
Satan close quote so whatever
contradicts the scriptures we can be
sure certain that it comes from Satan
and not
God and this is a book that according to
her is barricaded by a thus saith the
Lord selected messages book 3 page
122 so as we listen tonight remember
this the SDA Church tells us that those
words from Ellen White are divine
revelation directly from the throne room
of God
himself this is one of those areas where
there's a lot of Truth mixed in with
error just like in Eden so hopefully
this will help you be able to cut
through the theological fog let's hear
how Dwayne thinks we can help God solve
his big problem ahead and let's get to
the screen because we got some exciting
things to cover over here so let's take
a look at this the Bible says something
that's very powerful how do we deal with
the sin problem because this is really
the thing that we want to consider is
how do we deal with this sin problem
well the Bible's very clear in Matthew 1
verse 21 and she shall bring forth a son
Thou shalt call his name Jesus for what
is he what is Jesus going to do he's
going to save his people what from their
sins he's going to save them from their
sins don't lose that thought from the
word from in the original language it
denotes separation departure I like the
next word
cessation completion reversal so when
Jesus says or when the Bible says he's
going to save his people from their sin
it is completely opposite of saving
people in their sins let me give it to
you this way I want you to imagine
there's a house burning burning in fire
there's a house burning in Fire and you
are surrounded by that fire and the fire
is closing in more and more and more so
naturally because you want to live
you're going to scream for help you're
going to say please help help me so a
person hears you and they are outside of
that fire and they say to themselves no
problem I'm going to come and get you so
here's what they do they take a blanket
and they dip it in a lot of water they
wrap it around themselves walk through
the fiery wall and now they're with you
together in the fire they wrap you
around in the blanket and then they say
stay right here and you both just stay
there question are you being saved in
the fire or are you being saved from the
fire you're being saved in the fire is
that a problem yes it is because as the
fire comes closer it's going to suck up
all the water it's going to start frying
that blanket and it's going to catch on
fire and then both of you are going to
die you got that bad solution so
scenario number two you're inside of the
house a fire bursts out it's surrounding
you you cry out for help help and then
somebody on the outside says don't worry
I'll come inside and help you they take
a blanket dip it in a lot of water they
wrap themselves up walk through the
fiery wall they say get in you get in
they pick you up and then walk outside
the wall and go all all the way down the
road to another place question are you
being saved in the fire or are you being
saved from the
fire you're saved from the fire because
now the fire is no longer a dangerous
reality in your life are you following
that Jesus did not
come to save mankind so they can keep on
sinning but just thank God for his
grace that's not
biblical
salvation but funny enough that's what a
lot of people
teach but what the Bible teaches is
Jesus is going to save us from our sins
meaning he's going to do something so
special so powerful that it actually
causes a
sensation in the person's life that the
things they used to do because of his
grace and
power and his
sacrifice they no longer do it anymore
and that to me is real Gospel Power so
let's yeah horrible analogy there all
right so a commonplace lots of Orthodox
Adventist start when seeking to make a
Biblical case for sinless perfectionism
because that's what Dwayne is getting at
here Matthew 1:21 according to this
interpretation folks which is by no
means unique to Dwayne lemon unless a
person is totally free from sin
already that would mean they cannot
rightfully say Jesus has saved
them because according to him Jesus
doesn't save people in the fire in their
sins in his analogy he said a person has
only been saved from the
fire if the fire is no longer a
dangerous reality in their life
and he said that according to some
people got to love that the Advent of
some people being saved is simply the
idea that you get your ticket Punch To
Heaven no real change in your life no
conviction over sin Etc yeah this is a
fringe minority of people and no formal
Christian confession of Faith puts this
forth so for those coming out of
adventism or those who have recently
left or in the process of doing so a
piece of advice that I would give you is
to always be on the lookout for these
types of claims from SDA teachers
they will utilize Fringe random
individuals somewhere but often posit it
like serious Orthodox Christian teaching
or problem not a single credible
Christian confession of Faith from the
Protestant Roman Catholic Orthodox
Coptic Assyrian Church of the East Etc
not a single one of them claims what he
said here but this sets the groundwork
for now comparing and contrasting the
SDA teaching with this nebulous group
Somewhere Out
There we've SE seen Ted Wilson do the
same thing Steven bore Doug Bachelor
John LOM mang countless other SDA
teachers so just make a mental note of
that always ask yourself if individuals
like this are actually appealing to any
sort of formal statement of faith or
just making some nebulous General
claim that salvation is understood to
mean that you basically just get a get
out of Fire free card but nothing
changes in your life no conviction over
sin Etc but a couple things to break
down here before we can proceed first is
that the word
saved well the word saved and it's very
Broad and wide
connotation we're going to get into some
technical uh theology tonight because
it's what will allow you to see right
through stuff like this so in Christian
theology folks there is a Latin phrase
called the OS
solutus which means the order of
Salvation now there are disagreements in
various theological camps regarding what
the order of these events are but the
purpose of tonight is not to exhaust all
of that rather it is to show how words
like saved can be rather ambiguous when
salvation actually encompasses a number
of different
doctrines typically what people are
referring to when they're talking about
what Dwayne posited is
justification but they don't believe
that justification is the only thing
that encompasses
salvation but some of the aspects of
Salvation according to scripture include
predestination election regeneration
Faith conversion perseverance repentance
justification sanctification
glorification and some other
aspects all of these doctrines could
rightly be nestled Under The Heading of
Salvation or in the theological realm of
soteriology so to use the word saved as
Dwayne did is not specific enough
because Christian theology upholds the
order of Salvation and the various
Christian Traditions argue amongst
themselves as to what the proper order
of these things is but what you won't
find is what Dwayne described that the
order of solutus only entails apparently
confessing you believe in Jesus and
that's it that's the single
step yeah no serious person says this
we'll talk more about that later on but
that's one two what Dwayne is putting
forth here is the administ teaching of
sinless perfectionism notice he said
Jesus doesn't save you in your sin but
from it and in one sense that's correct
no true Born Again believer is going to
be for uh you know forever remain in
their sins and trespasses but you'll
notice he added that a person has only
been saved from the fire if the fire is
no longer a dangerous reality in their
life so Dwayne is Apparently one of
these Adventists that's so holy that he
glows in the dark you know he's exempt
from uh praying The Lord's
Prayer or he's stating that he's not
saved one or the other I'm not sure but
here's what I do know this is an area
where adventism is in a serious
theological bind here's
why in testimonies for the church volume
two Ellen White is giving counsel to SDA
pastors but she also makes some claims
regarding all professing believers and
notice what she writes
quote some have erroneous ideas of what
constitutes a Christian and of the means
through which a firm religious
experience is obtained much less do they
understand the qualifications that God
requires his ministers to possess these
men are
unsanctified they have occasionally a
flight of feeling which gives them the
impression that they are indeed children
of God this dependence upon Impressions
is one of the special deceptions of
Satan those who are thus exercised make
their religion a matter of
circumstance firm principle is wanting
none are living Christians unless they
have a daily experience in the things of
God and daily practice self-denial
cheerfully bearing the cross and
following Christ every living Christian
will advance daily in the Divine Life as
he advances towards Perfection he
experiences a conversion to God every
day and this conversion is not completed
until he attains to Perfection of
Christian character a full preparation
for the Finishing Touch of
immortality close
quote so if you are a true Christian
according to
her you should experience a conversion
to God every day as you're on the
pathway to perfection in Dwayne lemon's
words as you are in the process of
exiting the
fire and this process of exiting the
fire is not complete until you have
attained to a perfect character
which is what you will have uh which is
what a person has to have in order to be
prepared for the Finishing Touch of
immortality this is tied to the SDA
teaching of
probation which Mrs White said in a uh
is a time for you to to achieve this
totally sinless character notice
quote we're not to settle down expecting
that a change of character will come to
us by some miraculous work when Jesus
shall appear in the Clouds Of Heaven
with power and great Glory no my young
friends we are judgement bound and
probation is granted to us here in this
life in order that we may form
characters for the future Immortal Life
close
quote so probation has been granted for
what
purpose to develop your character for
the future Immortal Life nothing is
going to change in your character when
Jesus returns so like she said in the
other quote conversion isn't completed
until you have attained to a perfect
character which is what you which is
what will have you prepared for the
Final Touch of being given
immortality which would mean that she is
claiming here that a person can Short
Circuit the ordos solutus and Achieve
glorification before the second coming
not only can you but you must in order
to be fitted for heaven in this
model this wasn't a one-off claim either
again she writes
quote Last Day
Events if you would be a saint in heaven
you must first be a saint on
Earth the traits of character you
cherish in life will not be changed by
death or by the resurrection you will
come up from the grave with the same
disposition you manifested in your home
and in society Jesus does not change the
character at his coming the work of
transformation must be done now our
daily lives are determining our destiny
defects of character must be repented of
and overcome through the of Christ and a
symmetrical character must be formed
while in this probationary state that we
may be fitted for the Mansions Above
close
quote so very clearly she is claiming
that a person must achieve total
sinlessness while on probation because
probation is a time for professing
believers to work on developing their
character for eternity nothing about
your character is going to change in
death or the resurrection you will come
up from the grave with the exact same
disposition you entered it with only
those that achieve this while on
probation will be fit for heaven and
ultimately make it into the new heavens
and the new Earth and probation is
closing soon so get busy get busy get
busy keep working keep working keep
working you'll never actually achieve
this because you're trying to Short
Circuit some well I don't want to get
ahead of myself but this is perfectly
consistent with great controversy
theology which is what Dwayne lemon is a
teacher of
however I mentioned that the SDA church
is in a bind on
this and that's because they've tried to
distance themselves from this teaching
despite telling us that Ellen White's
claims are divine revelation from God
himself in the exposition of the 28
fundamental beliefs they write
quote some incorrectly believe that the
ultimate Perfection that glorification
will bring is already available to
humans
but Paul wrote near the end of his life
not that I've already attained or am
already perfected but I press on that I
may lay hold of that for which Christ
Jesus has also laid hold of me Brethren
I do not count myself to have
apprehended but one thing I do
forgetting those things which are behind
and reaching forward to those things
which are ahead I press toward the goal
for the price of the upward call of God
in Christ Jesus Philippians 3:1
12-14 sanctification is is a lifelong
process Perfection now is only ours in
Christ but the ultimate all
comprehensive transformation of Our
Lives into the image of God will take
place at the second
coming
interesting so some people such as LG
white incorrectly taught and believe
that the ultimate Perfection that
glorification will bring is already
available to humans
meaning that it can be achieved prior to
the resurrection of the body or the
second coming sanctification is a
lifelong process they tell us and the
all comprehensive transformation of Our
Lives into the image of God will take
place
when at the second coming completely
contradicting their prophetess that this
same book tells us needs to be yielded
to in the SDA vocabulary the image of
God here is referring precisely to a
person's
character as Ellen White wrote in the
great controversy being made in the
image of God is referring to both the
way we physically look as well as our
characters well she said no change in
character will take place through death
or in the resurrection only immortality
will be granted to the physical body no
change in
character so which one is it
are Ellen White and Dwayne lemon
right or is the present Adventist Church
and the fundamental belief's book right
because you can't have it both
ways the consistent teaching from the
beginning has been what Ellen and Dwayne
are claiming because that's what's
consistent with the central idea that
God and His law are on trial they need
to be Vindicated from Satan's
accusations namely that the law is
unfair and can't be kept
and I could show you quote after quote
after quote of primary SDA Source
documentation stating as much stuff
that's modern not just old
either but let's talk about
glorification for a minute you know it's
interesting I I was talking with a
Eastern Orthodox friend today we were
talking about this exact subject just
happened to come
up it was interesting to me how similar
the idea is to Seventh Adventist the
ology almost the idea of of the current
life is like purgatory and you got to
purge yourself and get to this this
state where you can actually stand
before God and now it's not in the the
finer details it's not a oneto one but
just at a high level it's interesting
how similar it is I'm obviously going to
be making a case for glorification being
something other than um a a drawn out
process as you're going to see but the
great controversy model fundamentally
misunderstands
glorification it demands that a person
achieve something that cannot be
achieved yet and tells them that if they
don't they're not going to be fit for
heaven the model short circuits the
order of
Salvation you cannot achieve
glorification ahead of when God will
apply
it and glorification is actually unique
among the other doctrines pertaining to
Salvation and I will show you why in a
moment but first
in his fabulous little book Redemption
accomplished and applied Theologian John
Murray has some absolute
gems he walks through the order of
Salvation and shows how each step from
the scriptures is this long chain of
events that all take place over the
course of the life of the believer but
first he gives a succinct highlight of
what glorification is notice what he
says
quote glorification is the final phase
of the application of
redemption it is that which brings to
completion the process which begins with
effectual calling indeed it is the
completion of the whole process of
redemption for glorification means the
attainment of the goal to which the
elect of God were predestined in the
Eternal purpose of the father and it
involves the consummation of the
Redemption secured and procured by the
vicarious work of Christ but when this
glorification take place close close
quote so before proceeding folks another
word for Redemption is
salvation Salvation has two
aspects Adventist theology does not
grasp this and it's why they constantly
are crossing
wires you have Redemption
accomplished and then you have the
actual application of what Christ
accomplished Redemption was accomplished
in full in the Life Death burial and
resurrection of the Lord Jesus
Christ but it was not applied in full
during that time
frame the application of redemption
happens in various phases for example
all believers do not have the benefit of
regeneration happen at the same
time this happens to some people as kids
some people as young adults some as
elders and so
on it happens when God deems fit to do
such Redemption accomplished versus
Redemption applied please get
this including my Roman Catholic viewers
Orthodox
viewers this will help you be able to
better engage with Protestants on things
like the mass and where the real
disagreements would be but this is why
if you engage an Adventist on the
subject of atonement for example and you
say our sin was put away at the cross
which Hebrews 9:26 verbatim
says therefore the investigative
judgment makes no sense you will more
than likely be asked well if that's true
then why is there still sin in the world
how could it have been put
away and this is a valid question from
the SDA vantage
point because they've falsely been
taught a system that doesn't distinguish
between Redemption accomplished versus
Redemption applied
there is a now and a not yet component
to this in the accomplishment of
redemption Jesus put sin away in
full which is why sin can't condemn the
believer who's in Christ nothing can
Romans
81 it's why Protestants say the
atonement was completed in full at the
cross because atonement is nestled Under
The Heading of redemption
accomplished but at the same time sin is
still lurking in our world because
Redemption has not been applied in full
yet this will happen at the consummation
of the ages where Heaven and Earth unite
the resurrection happens glorification
is applied the curse is lifted off of
the creation Etc but until then sin will
still be
lurking but notice that Dr Murray notes
glorification is the means to what end
the attainment of the goal which God has
for the believer namely the total
consummation of redemption which
obviously involves total freedom from
sin well what Dr Murray says here isn't
unique to
him so just an observation there that
shows how this idea of being saved in
the fire to remain there is not
normative Orthodox Christian teaching
only Fringe pockets of individ uals key
word individuals affirm
this and everyone who disagrees with
Adventist theology should not be settled
with
this but Dr Murray ends with a vital
question when does glorification
specifically
occur well Romans
3:23 tells us that sin is
what to fall short of the glory of God
so let's just do some some thinking and
reasoning
here for all have
sinned and fall short of the glory of
God that's the causitive result of sin
falling short of the glory of God which
would mean if you no longer fall short
of the glory of
God you're
glorified so Romans 3:23 tells us that
to sin is to fall short of the glory of
God glorification is when this will no
longer be a thing a person will no
longer fall short of God's glory as they
will be
glorified but Dr Murray continues by
pointing out something absolutely
fascinating about glorification get this
this is very important to grasp
quote the Redemption which Christ has
secured for his people is redemption not
only from sin but also from all its
consequences death is the wages of sin
and the death of believers does not
deliver them from
Death The Last Enemy death has not yet
been
destroyed it has not yet been swallowed
up in
Victory hence glorification has in view
the destruction of death
itself it is to dishonor Christ and to
undermine the nature of the Christian
hope to substitute the blessedness upon
which Believers enter at death for the
glory that is to be revealed when this
corruptible will put on incorruptible
and this Mortal will put on immortality
1 Corinthians
15:54 preoccupation with the event of
death indicates a deflection of faith of
love and of hope we who have the first
fruits of the spirit grown within
ourselves the Apostle reminds us waiting
for the adoption the Redemption of our
body Romans
8:23 that is the glorification it is the
complete and Final Redemption of the
whole person when in the Integrity of
the body and spirit the people of God
will be conformed to the image of the
Risen exalted and glorified Redeemer
when the very body of their humiliation
will be conformed to the body of Christ
Glory Philippians
3:21 God is not the god of the dead but
of the living and therefore nothing
short of Resurrection to the full in
joyment of God can constitute the glory
of which the Living God will lead his
redeemed Christ is the first begotten
from the dead the first fruits of them
that have fallen
asleep he is the firstborn among many
Brethren this truth that glorification
must wait for the resurrection of the
body advises us that glorification is
something upon which all the people of
God will enter together at the same same
identical point in
time there is no priority for one above
another in this respect it radically
differs from death and the glory with
Christ upon which Saints enter on that
event each saint of God who dies has his
own appointed season and therefore his
own time to depart and be with Christ we
can see that this event is highly
individualized
meaning death it's highly individualized
we don't all die at the same time but it
is not so with
glorification one will not have any
advantage over another all together will
be glorified with
Christ close
quote so make sure you catch
this because we're going to look at the
scriptures that he's appealing to here
through the night don't think he's just
saying this willy-nilly because I can
already hear some you know where's the
Bible well he's citing the Bible friend
when scripture talks of
glorification when a person is changed
in the twinkling of an eye when their
lowly body puts on the Heavenly Body
when the corruptible is swn and raised
Incorruptible all of these ways the
Bible speaks of glorification this step
in the order of Salvation is unique in
that it is
universal it will happen to all
believers at the
exact
same
time the entire purpose of glorification
is the complete and Final Redemption of
the whole person Body and Soul where we
will be conformed to the glorified
likeness of Jesus
Christ okay so make sure you catch
that at the point of glorification Union
with Christ Christ will meet its final
consummation be applied in its fullness
and we will enter into beatific Vision
with our savior
okay so Ellen White was wrong you cannot
achieve a glorified state right now
through diligent effort paired with the
grace of God which is what the Orthodox
SDA teaching on perfectionism that
Dwayne is teaching is ultimately
claiming and it's why they're beating
people over the head with this
constantly it's like the hamster wheel
you must attain to a state where you no
longer sin in any way
whatsoever like I said earlier the
Adventist doctrine of probation is
similar to the Roman Catholic doctrine
of
purgatory while on probation you must
purge yourself of all sin entirely and
if you don't achieve such a condition
you won't secure the condition necessary
for the Eternal State and you're not fit
for
heaven which is to claim you must
achieve glorification while on
probation you must know longer fall
short of God's glory which is Romans
3:23 says sin is falling short of God's
glory teaching people that they must
achieve total sinlessness in their
current unglorified condition otherwise
they won't be fit for Heaven is a Pious
deception built upon a faulty
understanding of
glorification and from the looks of it
the present SDA Church even sees this
and was willing to go on record and
outright contradict their
prophetess but that has hasn't stopped
people like Dwayne lemon from still
teaching in accordance with Ellen
White it always always produces people
who can't distinguish law from gospel
justification from sanctification and it
results in them trying to add their own
Act of righteousness to the
righteousness of Christ and then their
own emotions determine whether or not
they have Assurance or they you know on
their standing before
God this is why the sacraments are so
important remembering your baptism
the reception of the Eucharist every
week not every 13 weeks every
week if you're in a church friend where
they're not taking if they if you're in
a church where they recoil at the phrase
Eucharist find a new church if you don't
take the Eucharist every week find a new
church these are the means of Grace
whereby salvation comes to us Jesus
gives us himself in them but I digress
when the sinless perfectionist Camp of
SDA utilize matthew2 one in this fashion
they are short Circ the order of
Salvation like Ellen White did they
clearly don't understand that
glorification is not just having a body
that is changed to be
immortal it will also impact a person's
character their
disposition because your body actually
influences those
things and this event will happen
universally at the same time for every
single believer but with regards to
Matthew 1:21
notice what Anglican Theologian JC RI
notes in his expository thoughts on
Matthew it's not a formal commentary but
I just love the way he words something
here and it's completely consistent with
what Dr Murray presented which is
ultimately just 1 Corinthians 15 and
Romans
8 Matthew is entirely consistent with
Paul notice what RI writes
quote the name Jesus means savior it's
the same name Joshua in the Old
Testament it's given to our Lord because
he saves his people from their sins this
is his special office he saves them from
the guilt of sin by washing them in his
own atoning blood he saves them from the
Dominion of sin by putting in their
hearts the sanctifying spirit he saves
them from the presence of sin when he
takes them out of this wicked to rest
with him or out of this world to rest
with him sorry meaning death he will
save them from all the consequences of
sin when he shall give them a glorious
body on the last day
blessed and holy are Christ's people
from sorrow cross and conflict they are
not saved but they are saved from sin
forever more they are cleansed from
guilt by Christ's blood they are made
meat for heaven by Christ's spirit this
is salvation he who Cleaves to sin is
not yet
saved close
quote so I just want to note again we
have seen a presbyterian Dr Murray and
an Anglican both put forth these
standard understandings of Salvation and
prove uh you know both prove that Dwayne
lemon's idea of save to remain in the
fire is wrong just want to point that
out again but as R highlights until
glorification we are not entirely out of
the fire that doesn't mean we're
clinging to the fire loving the fire
resisting Jesus by trying to stay within
the fire but at the same time climbing
Jesus has saved us from the fire or
anything like that
okay one last thing on this point
regarding scripture clearly teaching
that one won't be free from sin until
the consummation of all things notice
what St Augustine notes in his Trea us
on the gift of perseverance fantastic
little
book it is a sermon where he is
preaching through the Lord's Prayer he's
catechizing people in The Lord's Prayer
and he's highlighting how one aspect of
the prayer involves asking God to
persevere the believer such as when we
pray give us this day our daily bread
very interesting observation to to think
about that that yeah that is a prayer
about
perseverance God sustain me
physically regarding stanza 5 though of
the prayer Under The Heading the fifth
petition it is an heor of the pelagians
that the righteous are free from sin
notice what he writes quote this is what
I'm telling you about pelagianism
earlier quote in the fifth sentence of
the prayer we say forgive us our debts
as we also forgive our debtors in which
petition alone perseverance is not found
to be asked
for for the sins which we ask to be
forgiven are ped but perseverance which
saves us for eternity is indeed
necessary for the time of this life but
not for the time which is passed but for
that which remains even to its
end yet it is worth the labor to
consider for a little how even already
in this petition the Heretics who were
to arise long after were transfixed by
the Tongue of cyprian as if by the most
Invincible Dart of Truth for the
pelagians dare to say even this that the
righteous man in this life has no sin at
all and that in such men there is even
now A church not having spot or wrinkle
or any such thing which is the one holy
bride of Christ as if she were not his
bride who throughout the whole earth
says what she has learned from him
forgive us our debts but notice how the
most glorious cyprian destroys
these John also in his epistle warns us
and says if we say we have no sin we
deceive ourselves and the truth is not
in Us close quote so to top it all off
Ellen White as well as Dwayne lemon are
pelagian Heretics who teach that a
person can be totally perfect and free
from sin in this
life this is precisely one of the things
that the pelagians aant taught yes they
taught a lot of different things and a
lot of heresy and yes a lot of those
things were interconnected but in this
specific area the avenus great
controversy theology is
pelagian and St Augustine just like St
cyprian refuted them in the pelagian
controversy by showing how first John 1
18 very easily dismantles this
idea on top of this The Lord's Prayer
where Jesus himself teaches us to daily
pray for the Forgiveness of our
sins the apost OST Les ask him how
should we pray Believers and not not
lost people followers of Jesus hey Lord
how should we
pray and part of his instruction is to
take a posture of humility recognizing
you're not glorified you still fall
short of God's glory don't puff yourself
up don't be deceived into thinking you
don't need to pray the Lord's Prayer or
that you're somehow exempt from needing
to pray
it and what did Augustine and cyprian
appeal to
ah right scripture scripture all in all
the word saved is an umbrella term and
one must Define how they're using it and
be
specific Believers can rightly say that
they are saved if by saved a person
means they are reconciled to God the
Father through the person of Jesus
Christ and sealed by the Holy
Spirit Ephesians 1 plainly says this
but a Believer can also rightly say that
they are being saved like Paul verbatim
says in 1 Corinthians 118 where he says
the message of the Cross is foolishness
to those who are
perishing but to those of us who are
being saved it is the power of
God Paul is clearly using the phrase
being saved to Encompass various aspects
of redemption that have yet to be
applied that that were on the trajectory
to eventually have those promises
applied that he talks about in Ephesians
1 the spirit is given we're going to
look at this later the spirit is given
as a down payment guarantee of The
Inheritance that we have in Christ
Resurrection glorification these sorts
of
things Dwayne was correct to say that
Jesus doesn't leave us where he found us
I mean that's a that's a
fact but the subtle Deception comes in
when he adds that a person has not only
been saved from the fire or or a person
has only been saved from the fire if the
fire is no longer a dangerous reality in
their
life which implies that unless you have
achieved total
sinlessness you don't sin anymore you're
not actually saved and technically until
Jesus returns which is again is
consistent with Ellen White you you
shouldn't say that you're saved because
you're still surrounded by the
Temptation to sin so the fire is still
there until the second
coming you have a lot of work to do get
busy get busy get busy just burns people
out doesn't mean you shouldn't strive
for that but you shouldn't strive for it
with that thinking in the backdrop no
unbiblical pelagian heresy bad bad bad
theology that is ultimately rooted in
not understanding proper uh proper
biblical categories and what
glorification actually
is about this there's a story in the
Bible that fits this picture that you're
seeing this is a picture of a Serpent's
head and it's a picture of someone's
foot on a Serpent's
head this comes from something that
ultimately produced or told the story of
what's known as the
Everlasting God
gospel this is what it says it's found
in the Book of Genesis 3 and ver1 15
after Eve fell into sin it created a
very serious problem because now every
son and daughter of Adam and Eve were
born with a sinful nature a natural Bend
to do things that are sinful and wrong
so God puts This Promise out and here's
the promise that God says I will put
enmity or hatred between thee and the
woman and between thy seed and her seed
it shall bruise or break thy head and
thou shalt bruise his heel a lot of
people don't know but this was the
introduction of the Everlasting
gospel this was God making an
announcement of what he was going to do
to ultimately solve the sin problem
God said he was going to do something
very special and it was going to require
an incredible uh sacrifice but here's
the deal we need to identify the
characters in the verse we need to
understand the characters in the verse
so that way we can make sure we're
clearly following what this little
prophecy was saying we need to
understand who's the I because that was
stated in the verse we also need to find
out who's the woman because that was
out who's the seed cuz that was in the
verse and then we need to find out who's
the serpent because that was in the
verse okay now I'm going to ask you if
you if you're okay with it if you're not
okay with it just don't do it I'll just
look a little silly but if you're okay
with it I'm going to ask you to repeat
after me how can we understand these
characters that was in the Bible verse
this is how we can understand it I'm
going to ask you to repeat after me I
promise I will never mislead you here we
go ready
scripture scripture is the key is the
key that unlocks that unlock scripture
scpt don't ever forget that let's repeat
that one more time
scripture is the key key that unlocks
unlocks
scripture the
Bible beautifully interprets
itself that's how you understand
scripture
when you don't understand scripture
don't run to some part of the clergy and
just say please explain it I can't
understand it the Bible says cursed be
the man that puts his trust in
man we are to love people but don't put
your trust in them I don't read that in
the Bible but what does God say God says
remember my words interpret themselves
God's word can explain itself so when we
want to find out who's the eye who's the
woman who's the seed who's the serpent
we're going to learn a little bit about
how to study the Bible right now we're
going to let scripture be the key that's
going to unlock scripture so let's go
ahead and
start so don't consult with other
people about scripture he
says that's supposedly putting your
trust in man according to Jeremiah
17:5 but at the same time he's going to
teach people how to interpret the Bible
after abusing Jeremiah 17 my the irony
don't put your trust in man he says oh
Dwayne you mean like Ellen
White your church literally tells us
she's the infallible interpreter of the
Bible and if you have an understanding
that departs from hers you have to yield
to
her is this a joke scripture can't be
the key that unlocks scripture when the
SDA Church tells us we can't even
understand the scriptures without Ellen
White's
writings which would mean Ellen White is
the key to unlock the
scriptures her her writings supposedly
uplift the normative character of such
and correct inaccurate interpretations
of them this is the constant catch22
that they're stuck
in but in a sheer sense of
irony I guess the SDA church is cursed
by God according to
Dwayne because if that isn't trust in a
single person's understanding of
scripture then I don't know what is
nevertheless this is another opportunity
to once again reiterate that seventh day
adventism is not Protestant and I'm
going to keep beating this
drum this was the anabaptist roots of
adventism shining through and it's part
of why aist theology is such a dumpster
fire the anabaptist had this who cares
about tradition who cares about the
theological Giants of the past who
oftentimes gave their lives for the
preservation of the scriptures attitude
this is such a toxic
mindset and it explains why so many
Adventists not all not all not all but
many have an arrogance that is
impenetrable because they think they're
the ultimate Arbiter of biblical
truth the Bible means whatever it means
to them personally often resulting in
entirely novel interpretations of the
Bible
I want to remind everyone that SDA
historian Dr George Knight notes in his
book search for identity that seventh
day Adventists are not Heirs of the
Protestant
Reformation leading Seventh Adventist
historian folks not Joe
Blow and he notes that they are Heirs of
the anabaptist radical reformers who
were theological
anarchists the the anabaptist movement
folks was a bunch of revolutionaries not
reformers who were against both the
Roman Catholic church and the Protestant
reformers with a lineage back to the
Roman Catholic
Church the reformers had actual lineage
to the Roman
Church the anabaptists were just a bunch
of
radicalists and they claimed the
Protestants were still too Catholic
quote unquote these are the same charges
you'll hear from these types to this day
if you use words like Eucharist you talk
of the Eucharist as a sacrifice liturgy
Creeds and confessions especially infant
baptism which is where the name
anabaptist comes from it literally means
re-baptized
so let's take a small trip down history
Lane on this okay Story Time with
answering
adventism so there was an anabaptist
fanatic by the name of Thomas
muner muner reject Ed the church's
hierarchy
entirely he rejected the sacraments as a
means of Grace he believed that the
institutional church had strayed from
true Christianity and it needed to be
replaced with a radical spirit-led
community of
Believers the spirit was uniquely with
them in this special way totally
detached the scriptures from history and
the church and lots and lots
more all of this stuff was part of
moner's broader revolutionary Vision
which also targeted both political and
economic structures that he saw as being
unjust and you'll see how Dr Knight is
correct that the Adventist disposition
is far more closely aligned with the
radicalists like muner and it's a
perfect example that Reformation is not
the same as
Revolution Reformation is not the same
as
restoration reform is something that
seeks to bring change to something
already in
existence restoration is seeking to
revive something that's dead and
revolution is seeking to start something
entirely new
altogether so I don't want to camp out
on this for too long but it is
insightful regarding Dwayne's Claim
about not Consulting any man regarding
understanding the
Bible this is from the third volume of
Martin Luther's biography which is
written by German historian Martin br
Which documents down the Final 14 or so
years of Luther's life it was during
that time that Luther had his runin with
the anabaptist in mster not to be
confused with Thomas muner but the town
of
mster from the bookshelf behind me
notice
quote at the beginning of 1534 Dutch
anabaptist came to moner and soon
thereafter took over the government of
the city which touched off in an emperor
wide action against the city
Luther apparently paid little attention
to the events there at first in July he
replied to a question from mikias who
had been shaken by Bernard rothman's
argument that Christ had not assumed
true Humanity from Mary the true
Humanity of Christ was not to be doubted
later in the year Luther at the request
of his elector sent an emissary to so to
obtain some precise information about
the situation in Monster in mid November
he knew that John of Leiden had been
crowned king of of monster and that
eight of his Messengers had been
executed in
so in addition to the military action
against the monster anabaptist a
theological conflict with them was
already underway in
1534 amsdorf published thesis attacking
rothman's Doctrine on baptism on the
Catholic side John Coches several times
published reputations of anabaptist
articles in them pointedly blaming
Luther for the Abominations in Monster
at the beginning in 1535 a reputation of
the confession of the new valentinians
and donatus at mster was published in
vitberg by
urbanus the lunburg reformer it was
directed against the confession of faith
and life of the Church of Christ at
monster which Rothman had published in
the spring of 1534 and it identified his
statements as ancient heresies it's
preface was written by
Luther in it he took issue with two
accusations
in Monster people had said that he was a
false prophet talking about Martin
Luther even worse than the pope
conversely the papists regarded him as
partially responsible for the
Insurrection in moner and the heresies
there Luther took this with
self-confident equ equal
unanimity without him the Fanatics would
have never been able to criticize the
pope and conversely the papus would not
have been able to withstand them
he did not deny that the Fanatics had
come from him it had always been that
way Judas had been one of the disciples
all Heretics had Arisen in the church
itself and they drew their false
teaching from the Bible therefore the
accusations of the old Believers were
illogical close
quote so there's a lot that could be
gleaned from this so in 1534 the
anabaptist took over the government in
the city of moner and they began
teaching a bunch of ancient heresy that
they had resurrected trying to use the
Bible for their
support and as you can see they didn't
like the Protestant reformers or the
Roman Catholic church and Luther got to
hear it from both sides the anabaptist
called Luther a false prophet who was
worse than the
pope often times claiming that he was
still basically a Roman Catholic who
didn't go far
enough at the same time the Roman
Catholic Church blamed Luther for the
anabaptists and said they're your fault
this is all your
fault to which Luther in in true Luther
fashion took that as a compliment
because he pointed out how Heretics have
always risen from within the
church just like a a slight stab of well
yeah of course
we I
digress this is still the charge we see
made to this day against Protestants
that all these sectarian groups like The
Seventh Adventists and other offspring
of the anabaptist well they're the fault
of the Protestants and then we have to
claim them as our own because of that
you know think of the 33,000
denominations myth for
example but my point is that this is
what the 7 Adventist movement actually
hails from not
protestantism they bear almost all of
the Hallmarks of anabaptism just like
the anabaptist entirely detached the
scriptures from those that came before
them and didn't consult with anyone but
themselves so too we see Dwayne lemon
advocating the same thing and every time
folks every time people do this it
results in theological Anarchy and
heresy Consulting with other people in
the body of Christ regarding
understanding scripture is not putting
your trust in
men it's trusting that God works through
his church his body to sharpen and
mature
others but I appreciated this clip from
Dwayne because it allows me to reiterate
seventh day adventism is not Protestant
I'm gonna continue beating this drum
this is a personal axe that I have to
grind
you know advents want to talk aboutou
seem angry you seem this you seem that I
don't have an ax to grind with adventism
just on every single thing I bring up
but this is an area I do have an axe to
grind with them
on these folks will try and tell us that
they're Heirs of the Protestant
reformers and then say silliness like
this which
shows the hand that Dr Knight so plainly
states they're
holding that the Protestant tradition
views the fathers of both the patristic
and Middle Ages as ministerial
authorities while we don't believe that
they are infallible or divinely inspired
writings that doesn't mean they don't
possess
Authority and if you read anyone like
Luther vermilia zanki buer Bullinger
you're going to read a lot of the
fathers Master zonki for example in his
Jerome zki in his on the
Incarnation which is basically just a
building Upon A systematizing of
athanasius's on the
Incarnation he cites over 30 of the
Fathers as well as Peter Lombard and
Thomas aquinus so both in early and high
Middle Ages Theologian and he does so to
show a consistent train of thought in
both scripture and throughout the life
of the church not a novel private
interpretation on these
things to help clarify in the Protestant
TR
tradtion you'll see why I keep bringing
up the Protestant tradition even though
Dwayne did not mention the word
Protestant he mentioned the phrase
scripture interpreting scripture we'll
get to that in a moment but in the
Protestant tradition ministerial
Authority refers to the authority given
to church
leaders to teach preach discipline
Shepherd the flock
Etc this Authority is derived from the
scriptures and is seen as servant based
rather than absolute
infallible ministerial authorities are
accountable to God and the church
community and their Authority is limited
by the word of
God so Paul himself gives an example of
this in Galatians where he says that
even he an apostle of Jesus Christ he is
subordinate to the gospel message that
Jesus gave the apostles this can be
derived from the ever so popular portion
that I site on here all the time he says
he or an angel from heaven comes
preaching a gospel contrary to the one
that that they received from
Jesus the word of God let him be
anathema so Paul was even subservient to
the word of God another example in
Matthew 15 Jesus is engaging with the
Jewish
leadership and he recognizes he says you
guys sit in the seat of
Moses they possess legitimate Authority
but he then chides them for setting
aside in Jesus's words the Commandments
of God for the traditions of the
elders not just this but he points out
numerous times in his ministry how the
ministerial Authority got things wrong
and needed to correct in light of
scripture so Jesus makes the distinction
between the tradition of the ministerial
Authority and the scriptures themselves
ministerial Authority is distinct from
canonical Authority
which refers to the authority of
scripture itself as the inspired and
sole infallible rule of faith in other
words no Minister Church Council or
tradition can override or add to the
Canon of scripture that's basically what
it's
saying what's funny is how SDA Scholars
will try and bring up this distinction
regarding Ellen White and say she
doesn't hold canonical Authority we
don't add her to the scriptures she's
like a ministerial Authority yet despite
her writings allegedly being inspired
and infallible correcting of inaccurate
interpret ations of scripture and unlike
a localized Prophet they have her
functioning exactly like a canonical
Prophet whose writings hold Authority
beyond the life of the
Prophet nevertheless hopefully that is
helpful for those trying to Wade through
the differences here just because an
authority isn't infallible doesn't mean
they're not in Authority the vast
majority of authorities that God has
instituted are not infallible the
government parents pastors
Etc if someone is coming up with
entirely novel interpretations of a
passage of scripture in the year 2025
major red flags
folks this is the charge that's often
falsely raised against the reformers as
though that's what they did now I'm
sorry that's just not true and most of
them when you read their commentaries
mention all of the known interpretations
that they were aware of and then they'll
tell you which they align with and why
typically doing so from the grammar of
the text but speaking of Novel inter
interpretations Dwayne cited Jeremiah
175 to try and support the idea that
cursed is the man who consults other
individuals regarding what the Bible
teaches Dwayne thanks for serving this
up on a silver platter because he
provided a perfect example of how he
should have consulted others before
trying to abuse the Bible in this
way so Jeremiah 17 is in the middle of
Jeremiah's highlighting of Judah sin
their their sin against God which was
described in a previous chapter Jeremiah
16 like
19 somewhere around in there but
notice judah's sin is engraved with an
iron tool inscribed with a flint point
on the tablets of their hearts and on
the horns of the altars even their
children remember their altars and Asher
up holes beside the spreading trees and
on the high hills my mountain in the
land and your wealth and all your
Treasures I will give away as plunder
together with your high places because
of sin throughout your
country through your own fault you will
lose the inheritance I give you I will
enslave you to your enemies in a land
you do not know for you have kindled my
anger and it will burn
forever this is what the Lord says
cursed is the one who trusts in man who
draws strength from mere flesh and whose
heart turns away from the Lord that
person will be like a bush in the
wastelands they will not see Pro
Prosperity when it comes they will dwell
in the parched places of the desert in a
salt land where no one lives and thus
the reading of God's holy
word so does this have anything to do
with Consulting other people regarding
biblical
interpretation better yet did Dwayne
utilize the historical grammatical
method of Bible interpretation that Ted
Wilson keeps telling us is the only
approved hermen in the SDA
Church yeah of course not because he's a
scriptural
pervert so like I said this is this is
connected back to Judah sin in Jeremiah
16 the imagery of an iron pen and a
diamond point would suggest that Judas
sin was permanently inscribed both
externally like on the altars of
idolatry and internally on their
hearts it was a deeply rooted sin and in
their idolatry they had made altars to
balum and despite King Josiah bringing
about reform it didn't take long for it
to return under
jeim showing How Deeply ingrained the
sin was within them but verse five is
what Dwayne proof texted in passing to
try and say if you consult anyone else
about understanding the Bible you're
trusting in men and those that do such
are cursed by God I mean what an
absolute twisting of of the scriptures
this talking about
idolatry you're not worshiping or
idolatry idolizing someone as a God by
simply learning from those more mature
in the
faith those who you can clearly see the
spirit of God within yeah you're not
cursed for doing that God works through
means folks no nowhere does the Bible
say everything contained within it is
easily understood it's all crystal clear
any Joe Schmo can just pick it up and
just understand everything within
it such an idea just goes against common
sense and simple
observation brand new Christians don't
know just as you know much about
scripture hermeneutics different
literary genres as an individual that's
dedicated their entire lives to this
field just one example doesn't mean the
knowledgeable person's always right but
it's just silly to say you're cursed is
the man that trusts in men
be but Dwayne mentioned the popular
Reformation slogan of scripture
interpret scripture that's why I was
getting at the history there previously
about them being
anabaptist let's clear some theological
fog here this is very
important Dwayne you all don't let
scripture interpret scripture because
you guys have an alleged infallible
interpreter and magisterium housed in
the writings of Ellen G white
just like the Roman Catholic Church in
in catechism paragraph 100 where they
say the magisterium holds the sole
infallible interpretive authority of the
scriptures this slogan was said within
the larger context of the Reformation
debate over scriptural sufficiency and
its sole
infallibility your movement affirms
neither and outright tells us we need
the writings of Ellen White and the
Revelation contained within them to
actually understand the Bible the
Bible's not sufficient in and of itself
and it's not the sole infallible rule of
faith and
practice the claim that scripture
interprets scripture has been severely
misunderstood in the modern day by
sectarian groups like sdas historically
that phrase has been understood to mean
that the clear parts of scripture
interpret the unclear parts of scripture
not the other way
around it's not saying that you
Hopscotch all over the Bible like we see
Dwayne doing where they find a word
somewhere and then another text that
uses the same word followed by engaging
in word concept fallacy resulting in
oftentimes your own private
interpretations of
scripture like the investigative
judgment or that the Sabbath is the Seal
of
God but you know what's fascinating
about Dwayne using this phrase after
telling us not to listen to any man when
it comes to what the Bible is teaching
this is the exact thing the individuals
that coined this slogan were against the
irony notice Lutheran reformer Martin
kemnetz the other Martin in his
examination of the Council of Trent this
is from book 1 Section 5 titled
testimonies of the ancient Church
concerning the
scriptures remember for those that don't
know the Council of Trent was held in
response to the Protestant Reformation
kemet's writes quote
what we have thus far uced from the very
words of scripture are the firmest of
firm testimonies on which a Pious heart
can safely
rest for they set before us the Judgment
of the Holy Spirit himself concerning
the scripture for as the Ancients say
that concerning God nothing should be
believed except on the basis of his own
Revelation and testimony so also we
should believe about the scripture what
the scripture says about itself or
rather what its author the Holy Spirit
himself concludes and declares about his
work but we shall also add the consensus
of the ancient Church concerning the
authority Perfection and sufficiency of
the scripture for we love and venerate
the testimonies of the ancient and pure
Church by whose agreement we are both
aided and confirmed but our faith must
rest on the word of God not on human
authority therefore we do not set the
testimonies of the fathers over the
scripture but subordinate them to it
close
quote so Roman Catholics are obviously
going to disagree with kemet's use of
the fathers interpreting the father's
words has always been the debate but the
point is that this is an example of
someone who affirmed the Reformation
slogan of scripture interprets itself
and what did he do to bolster such a
concept he appealed to both scripture
and other learned individuals in the
church
in fact look at what Elsie says when
pointing out what Peter says in second
Peter
1:20 this is later on in Section 8 which
is titled concerning the interpretation
of
scripture he's responding to the canon
in the Council of Trent which states
that anyone who interprets the
scriptures apart from the Roman Catholic
Church The maerial Authority should be
reported and punished with penalties
appointed by law
because what was happening again these
were individuals that were Roman
Catholic teachers
leaders and they they bought into
Reformation theology depending on the
region they were in chemet is in
Germany and they began teaching it
within their local church in their
Parish so they the Roman Catholic Church
obviously had to do something about this
and so the Canon came down that if you
catch a person who depart hting from
this dogmatic
declaration they need to be
reported so in response to this Canon
chemets writes
quote this also is certain that no one
should rely on his own wisdom in the
interpretation of the scripture not even
in the clear
passages for it is clearly written in
second Peter 1:20 the scripture is not a
matter of one's private interpretation
and whoever twist the Holy Scripture so
that it is understood according to his
preconceived opinions does this to his
own destruction second Peter
3:16 the best reader of the scripture
according to St Hillary is one who does
not carry the understanding of what is
said to the scripture but who carries it
away from the
scripture we also greatfully and
reverently use the labors of the fathers
who by their commentaries have
profitably clarified many passages of
the
scripture and we confess that we are
greatly confirmed by the testimony of
the ancient Church in the true and sound
understanding of the scripture nor do we
approve of it if someone invents for
himself a
meaning close quote yeah this is the
actual Protestant position regarding the
interpretation of scripture not unique
to the Lutheran
here kemnetz explains in this section
how the the charge that the reformers
were these Rogue agents when it came to
scripture is false it's not
true this is still a false charge that
is made about them to this
day but I guess we can add Martin Kemet
and all the Protestant reformers to the
list of cursed individuals because
according to Dwayne lemon they
uphold that one can't rely solely on
their own wisdom in understanding the
Bible all by themselves even if they
have the Holy Spirit within them even in
the clear
passages this also squashes the myth
that solos scriptura is Bible
onlyism so so don't get it twisted folks
don't get it twisted seventh day
adventism is not Protestant they don't
Revere the
fathers whether it be those of the
patristic or Middle
Ages they don't consult them when
seeking to understand
scripture or how it's been understood
through the centuries do you see Seventh
Day Adventist maybe they're out there
somewhere shown to do you see Adventists
out there that
utilize uh be the venerables Commentary
on Revelation since they love the Book
of Revelation do we see them utilizing
uh Andrew of cesaria Commentary on
Revelation no
no Protestants get a bad rap in this
area and it drives me
crazy we're not Bible
onlys that's the anabaptist and their
offspring the modern evangelicals not
Protestants just because we don't think
the church or the fathers are infallible
doesn't mean they don't hold any
Authority the reality is the fathers are
not unanimous on the vast majority of
their
interpretations that's just a fact it's
just a fact it takes you about two
seconds of reading their commentaries
and their homes to see this that doesn't
therefore mean though that you can't GL
and learn from
them you can you can trace development
and and ret there's a lot of stuff
there that shouldn't be concerning or
shocking given the context in which they
lived the theological focuses of the day
Etc that they couldn't exhaust every
possible doctrine that scripture speaks
about they weren't systematic
theologians that's the other problem you
get people that you can't read them like
a Systematic Theology
textbook some of the fathers didn't even
have access to all of scripture like
Justin Justin Martyr I love Justin he
didn't even have access more than likely
to Paul's
Epistles but
furthermore various interpretation
methodologies developed in the varying
regions of the
church such as Origins alexandrian
school over and against the Antioch
school that's just within the Eastern
branch of the
church so it would do SDA teachers and
leaders well to stop trying to ride the
coattails of the Protestant
reformers and try to Hitch their wagon
to them they all would have denounced
Seventh Day Adventist
theology all that SDA leaders and
teachers do when they try to make it
seem like their Heirs of the Protestant
Reformation is Muddy the waters and
confuse
people as well as give Canon fodder to
Roman Catholic and Orthodox apologists
who try and saddle us with their
nonsense like they did Luther in monster
which doesn't actually move the
conversation forward in any real
way but all in all Jeremiah 175 is
basically just affirming the same thing
as Psalm 188 it's better to take refuge
in the Lord than to trust in
man it's talking about placing your hope
your heart your faith your security in
In the Flesh in man it's not advocating
for
biblicism and seeking to interpret the
Bible in your own isolated pocket of of
reality apart from the body of Christ
but with regards to Genesis 3:15 and the
Proto
euangelion the the Proto that's just the
the fancy way for the first giving of
the Gospel in Genesis
3:15 the first proclamation of the Good
News by God himself to Adam and Eve has
nothing to do with what the SDA Church
calls the Everlasting
gospel nor was it the introduction of
such this is where for those who are un
unfamiliar you would have heard what he
said here about this was the first many
don't know but this was the first you
know giving of the Everlasting
gospel yeah if you're not familiar with
all this you're not going to understand
what all is being imported into that
phrase Everlasting
gospel because it is absolutely the
first proclamation of the Gospel the
gospel of scripture in history The
Gospel that Jesus gave the apostles and
is deposited in sacred
scripture not the false Adventist gospel
which is informed by a pre-earth origin
story
where Jesus became an angel to fight
with Satan for 4,000 years this is all
part of his work his person and
work he became an angel to battle with
Satan for 4,000 years as an angel to try
and save the Angels but they all
rejected him so then in his humiliation
step one was to sink down to be an angel
he sheathed his Angel nature and put on
a human nature and sunk down even lower
and this was an act of eternal Eternal
humiliation where he forever lost Divine
attributes such as
omnipresence a narrative that also
falsely asserts that Jesus and Satan are
at war with one another over the Ten
Commandments because Satan became
jealous that Jesus was exalted to be
made equal with God the father so he
began attacking God's government or law
a narrative that claims Jesus's person
and work involves an investigatory
period which began in
1844 where where he's walking out the
work of showing who is and isn't fit for
heaven through the achievement of
sinless perfection which silences Satan
and vindicates God's
law that's the sort of information that
informs the Adventist Church's handling
of the Bible and Genesis 3:15 is no
exception by Jesus coming and crushing
Satan's head they would import into this
that that happened by Jesus keeping the
law perfectly vindicating it before all
of creation proving that Satan is a liar
his accusations in this prear origin
narrative are false and by going to the
Cross to be sacrificed he showed that
the law is
immutable yeah that's not what the Bible
teaches about why Jesus
came it's not what the scriptures teach
about why Christ incarnated why he
suffered under the hands of Sinners or
why he went to the
cross and that isn't at all what God
informed Adam and Eve of
we will talk about this phrase
Everlasting gospel in a little bit but
let's continue to listen to him teach us
how the Bible is to be interpreted after
telling us not to listen to or trust any
man in doing
such the ey was none other than
God in verse 14 it says and the Lord God
said and then the next verse says I will
put enmity between you and the woman so
the eye eye is who the eye is God
himself then it said the woman oh well
that requires a little bit of Bible
study so let's take a look the Bible
says I have likened the daughter of Zion
these are God's people I have liken the
daughter of Zion to a comely and
delicate
what woman and then Isaiah 51 and: 16
helps us understand who Zion is it says
say unto Zion you are
my people so the woman represents God's
people okay God's people or you could
say the
church then you have the seed well who's
the seed Galatians helps us with that in
chapter 3 now to Abraham and his seed
were the promises made he saith not and
to seeds as of many but as of one and to
thy seed which is who Christ so who's
the seed Jesus Christ very good lastly
the serpent Revelation 12 says and the
Great Dragon was cast out that old
serpent called what the devil and Satan
which deceives the whole world do you
see how we just use scripture to be the
key to unlock scripture we let the Bible
interpret itself that's the way you
always study scripture let the Bible
explain itself so watch this
the eye is God the woman is the church
or God's people the seed is Jesus and
the serpent is the devil and
Satan so God makes it very clear that
because of this seed which is Jesus this
seed God was going to use it to crush
the head of the
serpent but it did say that the serpent
was going to bruise his heel so that
means that the seed was going to go
through some suffering as well is that
right but because of this because of the
seed which is Jesus crushing the head of
the serpent which is Satan the Bible
says God is going to do something
absolutely
miraculous you know what it is he said
hatred will come in our hearts between
the woman us and the serpent Satan you
know why that's a miraculous statement
because in this world when we're born in
this world we have a nature that likes
Satan we have a nature that likes the
things that Satan promotes in this world
we have a nature that does not like
God in our natural nature we don't like
the things of God Romans 8 says our
carnal minds are at hatred with God and
so Jesus is going going to do something
that actually is miraculous he's going
to change the whole LoveHate scenario
Jesus is going to actually do like I
told you because of the fact we allowed
sin in our heart and it caused
separation Christ says that's okay I'm
now going to come in your heart and I'm
going to cause a separation he's going
to actually get us to hate what we
normally loved and he's going to get us
to love what we normally hated this is a
miracle this is the gospel encased in
one verse and you know why it's called
Everlasting gospel because the impact
lasts
forever it's not going to be a moment in
time that we hate the things of the
devil but one day we're going to come
back and love it nope the Bible lets us
know the gospel is so powerful that its
impact its effects are everl
lasting yes the gospel has Eternal
implications and everlasting
impacts but the SDA Church doesn't have
the gospel D Wayne
he he mentioned being cursed for
Consulting other individuals regarding
understanding the Bible earlier well
Galatians 1 dway says anyone preaching a
false gospel is cursed by
God what the SDA church has is an
everlastingly cursed
gospel SDA Theologian John Pauline in
his teaching course on Revelation 14
this a Collegiate level course folks New
Testament 386 7th Day Adventist
perspective on Revelation
online teaching course openly states
that seventh Adventists have their own
version of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ it's not the same gospel Jesus
Christ gave to the apostles this is the
dean of religion at Linda University not
a Joe
Schmo a person ignorant of Orthodox SDA
teaching but notice what Dwayne left off
when discussing the gospel being
Everlasting
he focused on it having Eternal
ramifications but not that it's
Transcendent and doesn't
change there's not various versions of
it which is why adventism is Under The
Curse Of
God it doesn't just have everlasting
effects but it is a fixed Transcendent
Everlasting message of the good news
about the person and work of Jesus who
he is what he accomplished and how you
as a sinner can be made right before
your
maker as I've shown before and could
show a mountain of quotes on the SDA
Church defines the Everlasting gospel as
their whole system of
doctrines 7th Day sabari anism the
investigative judgment the gift of
Prophecy in the writings of Ellen White
and numerous other things that have
nothing to do with the good news about
who Jesus is and what he accomplished
the gospel is the power of God to
Salvation for all that believe it
believe it believe it Romans 1:16-17
believing the writings of Ellen G white
has nothing to do with the power of God
the
Salvation they just hitch their entire
wagon of Theology and troan hor it into
the phrase Everlasting
gospel Dwayne said in Genesis 3:15 God
proclaimed the Everlasting gospel to
Adam and
Eve well this obviously has to mean this
Everlasting gospel changes and morphs
over time because I highly doubt that
any Adventist worth their salt would
claim that what this article here
describes as the Everlasting gospel is
what God proclaimed to Adam and
Eve
like was was God proclaiming to to Adam
and Eve Ellen White
but let's look into this a little
further notice how the SDA Church tries
to skirt around the
fact that they teach and preach a cursed
Gospel According to Galatians 1 from
their Church paper the review and Herald
again this is the September 13 1984
issue they published an article titled
is there a Seventh Day Adventist
gospel interesting they write quote
the same basic fact in a different
setting brings an entirely different
response apply this simple test to the
preaching of the
Gospel tell someone God loves you he
will forgive you your sins and give you
peace and joy that's very nice now tell
him God loves you and will forgive your
sins and make your life worthy of Heaven
even now he's judging who is worthy of
heaven and who must be destroyed he
began this judgment in 18 44 and soon
will come to the names of those now
living probation is soon to close tell
me quickly what must I do to be
saved the Judgment hour message of
Revelation with its truth about the
investigative judgment the mediatorial
work of Christ and the second coming is
to bring life and power to the preaching
of the Everlasting
gospel this makes adventism unique God
has favored his people with special
light to be
shared God has had a specific setting
for the presentation of his saving
messages throughout all
generations Noah preached the gospel in
the setting of God's desire to save that
generation there could have been many
people in Noah's day who believed in the
gospel of Christ they may have accepted
the teaching that God someday would send
his son to deliver them but they
rejected the
ark their gospel lacked the urgency of
the coming flood hence was not
sufficient to lead them into a saving
relationship with
God it may have produced a certain
amount of religious feeling but any
gospel that did not motivate them to
enter the ark left them to perish in the
cold
Waters zedekiah the last king of Judah
wanted the Prophet Jeremiah to give him
Assurance of God's power to save his
people but he did not want to accept it
in the setting that Judah was to submit
to the king of Babylon and wait for God
to turn their captivity at a later time
zedekiah rejected that message as a
result he suffered the wrath of
babylon's
armies God had a setting for the gospel
in Christ's day the Jews professed to be
custodians of God's grace for the world
their whole sacrificial system was a
detailed explanation of it but while
professing to believe they rejected the
gospel for their day in the setting of
the death of Christ so throughout time
the gospel has been preached against
different backdrops
for Noah it was the ark for those in
Christ time it was his life and
sacrificial death seen among them the
message of salvation for our day must be
seen against the backdrop of the
investigative
judgment close
quote so Christian this is how this
organization tries to claim they don't
have a different
gospel they try and claim there's just a
present truth aspect to the gospel that
changes in all
generations yet there's a core aspect
That Remains the Same in all of them so
the message of salvation's different in
all ages even if there are aspects that
are the same in all of
them and they love to point to the Old
Testament figures like you saw here to
say this proves as much no it doesn't
actually Noah didn't preach to people
get on the ark for the Forgiveness of
your
sins they are once again Crossing Ires
here in an attempt to justify what they
call the gospel and that it's entirely
novel to
them and they say that Noah may have
preached the good news that one day the
Messiah would come who will save a
people from their
sins but that wouldn't have been enough
for the person to have forgiveness for
their sins faith in that
message on top of that they would have
had to have gotten on the ark that was
the present truth component of the
gospel for that
time the present truth aspect in our day
in the end times is the novel Adventist
investigative
judgment so you can believe the good
news you can have faith in the person
and work of Christ which is the actual
power of God to Salvation for all that
believe
it but if you don't also affirm the
investigative judgment a Doctrine
entirely unique to the Seventh Adventist
Church didn't come from Bible study
came from a vision from a distraught man
in a cornfield the day after the great
disappointment was believed and then
taken to the Bible to try and find
meaning in the
disappointment you'll be just like those
in Noah's day who didn't get on the ark
and you'll be
lost none of that mess has anything to
do with what God foretold of AD to Adam
and Eve in Genesis
3:15 this is a crafty deception
and scripture twisting to try and prop
up the fact that this movement doesn't
have the Everlasting
gospel because the Everlasting gospel is
the gospel they say isn't enough in and
of itself to save
you you also have to embrace an alleged
present truth aspect that conveniently
only the SDA Church
teaches and this is why I said any SDA
worth their salt isn't going to say that
God preached the investigative judgment
to Adam and Eve as the Everlasting
gospel as part of the present truth only
for the end
times but at the end of the day they
can't change Galatians
1 they can try and ignore it twist it
claim Paul's hard to understand he's a
lawyer all these excuses they
give not going to change the facts the
Everlasting gospel in Revelation 14 is
the same good news that Jesus gave to
the apostles to take to the the world
starting in Jerusalem Luke 24 the good
news about the Forgiveness of sins
through faith in the person and work of
Jesus Christ that's the message that is
the power of God to Salvation for all
that believe it the gospel is not every
theological concept found in the
Bible the Bible talks about head
coverings for
women that's not the gospel just because
it's in the
Bible the gospel is very specifically
the good news a proclamation about who
Jesus is what he accomplished and how
you as a sinner can be made right with a
holy God it's also the good news about
his ruling and reigning his kingdom
being
established since the SDA Church teaches
that the investigative judgment is part
of Christ's
work they demonstrate that they preach a
false gospel one that scripture warns
about this isn't even touching like I
said earlier on the claim that he became
an angel to try and save
Angels which We examined a couple weeks
ago and found repeatedly affirmed by the
SDA Church as a part of the uh
Redemptive work of
Christ now watch
this the significant of a seed being in
us like we all know whenever you put a
seed into the ground it germinates it
Bud it sprouts and here's the beautiful
part it produces fruit after its kind so
watch this who so whoever is born of God
just look at this promise it's amazing
whosoever is born of God does not commit
sin for his
seed remains in him and he cannot sin
because he is born of God don't you want
that verse to be your
experience to have the seed of Christ so
deeply rooted in my heart that when
those things that the Temptations lead
us to we actually in our mind say how
could I do this and break the heart of
my God I cannot do
this that will be the mindset we'll be
kind of like Joseph with poyer's wife
when Piper's wife said hey come on sleep
with me and in his mind he said how
could I do this against my God don't you
want to get to a place that you and I
could actually have temptations come to
you come to me and we actually think to
ourselves how could I do this and break
the heart of my beloved savior who did
so much for me hold on okay Greg hold on
hold on
now yes and as we saw
earlier this will find its ultimate
fulfillment in glorification
Dwayne no Born Again person thinks to
themselves I want sin to just keep
flowing
in obviously the problem is what what
your model how it tries to shortcircuit
the OS
solutus you can't shortcircuit the
process you're not glorified you still
fall short of God's
glory and sin doesn't only come in the
form of
Temptation This is Insight actually into
how within SDA theology there's a lack
of understanding regarding the actual
depth and breadth of sin you can commit
sins of commission doing something that
you shouldn't you can also commit sin of
om Mission not doing something that you
should
be
furthermore Jesus taught that even
desires can be sinful in Matthew
5 this is the debate about concupiscence
being a
sin but in Colossians
3 Paul the Apostle also says the same
thing where he's talking about the born-
again believer should be actively Waring
to put to death the desires of the old
man
and then he lists out a handful of those
among the list he includes evil
desires so sin isn't just being tempted
and then acting upon an urge or desire
the desire itself can be sinful which
Rises up within a man due to still
living in a fallen human body that is
yet to be
glorified what I have found having
engaged with thousands of Adventists at
this point
is that most of them think something is
only a sin if there's some sort of
conscious awareness every time you
sin that God Winks at all the sins that
are committed that you're unaware of
yeah to which Romans 3:25 and acts 17:30
are pointed to typically to try and
prove this but neither of those texts
say that sin is only actually a sin if
one has complete and total knowledge of
it being
such we're going to engage in what
Dwayne said makes one cursed here notice
what Barnes notes regarding the Greek in
Acts
17:30 that's why I'm citing him by the
way I care about the
Greek and unlike we saw earlier where de
Dwayne simply cited a lexicon Barnes
discusses the phrase God winked at
contextually notice
quote the word can be translate
overlooked connived that did not come
forth to punish in Acts 14:16 it is
expressed thus who in times past
suffered All Nations to walk in their
own ways the sense is he passed over
those times without punishing them as if
he did not see them for wise purposes he
suffered them to walk in ignorance that
there might be a fair experiment to show
what people would do and how much
necessity there was for a revelation to
instruct them in the true knowledge of
God we are not to suppose that God
regarded idolatry as innocent or the
crimes and vices to which idolatry LED
as of no importance but their ignorance
was a mitigating circumstance and he
suffered the Nations to live without
coming forth in direct judgment against
them compare the notes on acts 3:17 and
acts
1416 close quote the text is not
saying that prior to Christ's coming sin
wasn't really sin or that people who
engaged in sinful practices weren't
actually engaging in sin because they
were ignorant of such Etc this is in the
middle of Paul's Mars Hill discourse
where he's engaging in apologetics with
pagans and Paul is simply explaining
that God has permitted for pagans to
walk out in their foolish and ignorant
behaviors of worshiping stones and
beasts to ultimately reveal the
necessity of Revelation from God to
instruct a person in the true knowledge
of God and God did this in the person of
Jesus Christ by entering into his own
creation which was a special Revelation
but simply put God winking at the times
of ignorance is speaking with regards to
God patiently allowing such to occur for
the purpose of God in Christ entering
into creation to reveal to us the
fullness of the truth which is why Paul
continues in the verse to say this time
of ignorance is up and God commands all
people everywhere to repent because the
revelation of God in Christ has now
occurred so I just want to put that out
there because again that's a typical
verse that a lot of them like to appeal
to to try and say well you know God
Winks at at sin yeah but that doesn't
mean it's not sin and and that a
person's still not accountable for such
things that's not what these texts are
saying but 1 John 3:9 is one of my uh uh
one of the favorite texts for pelagians
as well ironically this is after first
John 18 which tells you that if you
claim to have no sin you're a liar and
the truth isn't in you yet sinless
perfectionists will twist that or ignore
it and jump to to 1 John 3:9 and 1 John
3-4 Now by this we know that we know him
if we keep his Commandments he who says
I know him and does not keep his
Commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him and they'll try and prop up
the notion that if the seed of God is
within you you won't sin anymore again
notice what Barnes comments on this
verse
quote M the
Greek whosoever is born of God doth not
Comm commit sin on that
stanza he says quote this passage must
either
mean that they who are born of God that
is who are true Christians do not sin
habitually and characteristically or
that everyone who is a true Christian is
absolutely perfect and never commits any
sin if it can be used as referring to
the doctrine of absolute perfection at
all it proves not that Christians may be
perfect or that a portion of them are
but that all
are but who can maintain this who can
believe that John meant to affirm this
nothing can be clearer than that the
passage has not this meaning and that
John did not teach a Doctrine so
contrary to the current strain of the
scriptures and to fact and if he did not
teach this then in his whole passage he
refers to those who are habitually and
character characteristically
righteous then regarding the phrase for
his seed remaineth in him he notes
quote there is much obscurity in this
expression though the general sense is
clear which is that is something abiding
in the heart of the true Christian which
the Apostle here calls seed which will
prevent his sinning the word his in this
phrase his seed May refer either to the
individual himself in the sense that
this can now be properly called his in
as much as it is a part of himself or a
principle abiding in him or it may refer
to God in the sense that what is here
called seed is his that is he has
implanted it or it is a germ of divine
origin Robinson understands it in the
latter sense and so also do marnite or
uh sorry magnite Dodd luck and others
and this is probably the true
interpretation the word seed Sperma
means properly seed sewn as of grain
plants trees than anything that
resembles it anything which germinates
or which Springs up or is produced it is
applied in the New Testament to the word
of God or the gospel as that which
produces effects in the heart and life
similar to what seed that is sewn does
compare Matthew 13:26 Matthew 13 37-38
Augustine Clement grodus Rosen Mueller
Benson and Bloomfield suppose that this
is the signification of the word
here the proper idea according to this
is that the seed referred to is truth
which God has implanted or sewn in the
Heart from which it may be expected that
the fruits of the righteous will grow
but that which abides in the heart of a
Christian is not the naked word of God
the mere gospel or mere truth it is
rather that word as made vital and
efficacious by the influence of his
Spirit The Germ of the Divine Life the
principles of true piety in the soul
close quote so earlier I mentioned the
phrase ministerial Authority with
regards to the church fathers and and
just church leaders this is a perfect
example of what I meant by that so when
Barnes comments on scripture he does
this all the time or he does exegetical
work he does so in he he doesn't do so
in isolation and then just begin making
a bunch of claims about the text like
William Miller oh I sat down with a
concordance and I'm just gonna make a
bunch of claims and it's just me and my
Bible no Barnes consults with a wide
body of commentators from various
authentic Christian Traditions not just
his own because he doesn't have this
arrogant notion that he knows better
than everyone else that came before him
but he points out how this text can't be
saying what sinless perfectionist
claim that the person who's truly born
again will be sinlessly perfect prior to
the resurrection and glorification and
even as the SDA fundamental beliefs book
re uh reinforced later or
earlier this interpretation would
conflict with Paul in Philippians
3 the seed in this text is more than
likely referring to the gospel which is
implanted in like a seed Into the Heart
of an individual and this seed then
gives birth to righteous fruit in the
life of the individual because the holy
spirit is the one who Waters that seed
through the means of
Grace the gospel seed doesn't just get
implanted and then just sit there
dormant within a
person and this understanding is is
completely consistent with the fact that
one John already said in 1 John 18 that
if you say you're without sin you're a
liar and the truth isn't in you which is
what Augustine and cyprian pointed to
and two he says in chapter two that
prior to prior to this the individual
that makes a practice of sinning doesn't
know
God key word is
practice a person who makes a practice
of sinning what is practice it's when
you habitually are engaging in something
and it's a lifestyle you get better and
better at it you got no remorse you're
just doing it constantly all the time
you're not Waring against it that's
what's in in Focus here
the born- again believer feels
conviction over sin this again goes back
to the OS solutus it's not you're just
Justified and that's just
it no there's is whole chain of things
the spirit
does you can't Denude that out from the
rest of that stuff the spirit sanctifies
you regenerates you gives you a new
heart Born Again Believers should be
actively Waring against sin they long
for the resurrection and glorification
of the body which will finally set us
free from this lowly body of death with
all of its sinful incarnations
propensities and desires Romans eight
all the creation you know groans for
that day not just the the regenerate
believer but aanus loved to cite the
Book of Ecclesiastes when discussing the
state of man and death we read
Ecclesiastes 7 let's read it the same
way they read the book of Ecclesiastes
okay indeed there is no one on earth who
is righteous no one who does what is
right and never
sins all right contradicts Dwayne lemon
I can just read the text and just there
you
go so I guess the the preacher of
Ecclesiastes contradicts John
right this is in the flow of the
preacher laying forth wisdom it's why
most translations will include the
heading at the top that says
such and within the flow of that wisdom
he says there's no one on the earth that
never
sins valid observation that I've seen
with my own eyes so I ask again Dwayne
are you sinlessly
perfect are you exempt from that wisdom
are you one of these avist that want us
to believe that you're so holy you glow
in the dark you don't sin
anymore are you exempt from needing to
pray the Lord's
Prayer because according to how he
applied this text he doesn't have the
seed within
him but if he is saying that he's so
holy that he glows in the dark yeah
you're a liar and the truth is not in
you
now watch
this the Bible says to whom God would
make known what is the riches of the
glory of this mystery among the Gentiles
which is Christ in you the hope of glory
I've realized that this this idea of
Christ in US is a big theme in the Bible
I used to think it was just a a happen
stance statement but you're going to
find out that God really wants to dwell
in us he doesn't want just to be around
us he wants to be in us why because
that's what you do with seeds you bury
them in soil and your heart and my heart
represents that soil Christ wants to be
in you he knows this is the only way the
sin problem will be solved it cannot be
Christ around you it has to be Christ in
you there needs to be an intimacy a
Oneness between us and our god this is
the only way that the sin problem gets
solved because the one thing Jesus is
not going to do with you and not going
to do with me is he's not going to
Puppeteer us he's not going to make us
do things and make us not do things he's
not going to do that he's going to give
you that wonderful mind and and make you
reason and he's going to say you know if
you do this this is what will happen and
then he's going to give us all the grace
all the power all the love all the
wisdom that we can make decisions and do
something that a Old Testament Prophet
by the name of Joshua said we can choose
this day whom we will serve this is what
Jesus wants to do with us but the only
way this happens the seed must be in us
now let's yes it's absolutely true that
a person needs God dwelling within them
and how does that happen
Dwayne because he just moves along to
the next section of his
presentation he ended there by saying
that one must have the seed within them
after he cited 1 John 3:9 to say that if
you have any sin within you well the
seed must not be
there so Dwayne if you see this I ask
again are you so holy that you glow in
the
dark you're so holy you no longer need
to say the Lord's
Prayer or or are you stating that you
yourself don't have the seed within
you because based on what he said if you
follow along he stating that the seed
isn't actually within you if there's
still any sin in your life remember
earlier he said only when the fire is no
longer a danger can you say that you're
saved what an absolute travesty this was
this was the perfect opportunity for him
to talk about Union with
Christ which is what's actually at the
core in the heart of the Gospel not the
investigative judgment not sth day
sabari ISM and all this other nonsense
they try to call the
gospel not God being on trial and
needing to be Vindicated from charges
made by the
devil I talked about glorification now I
want to talk about my favorite subject
Union with Christ
okay and I will answer the question
about how one can have God dwelling
within them which in turn unites that
individual to Jesus Christ
himself you know Dwayne said I I used to
read this stuff in the Bible and think
it was just a passing thing know Christ
in
you yeah
no Union language Union with Christ
language hundreds of times in the New
Testament in Christ Jesus in Christ
we're about to look at a bunch of
these from the very beginning of the New
Testament Church Union with Christ has
been Central Primary to the Christian
faith like with almost all biblical
doctrines development takes place over
time where scripture is dug into harder
and then previous generations of
Believers build upon
it in other words every aspect of every
single doctrine of scripture wasn't able
to be exhausted in a single generation
silly to think that
that with that being the case there are
various nuances when it comes to the
believer's mystical Union with
Christ but generally speaking the same
thing is being said and has been
understood for 2,000 years
in the New Testament you will find over
200 instances of phrases like in Christ
in Christ Jesus in him Etc all of these
are statements pertaining to the
believer's union with Christ which is
the entire heart of the
Gospel so let's start from the
beginning scripture has a clear teaching
about all of Fallen Humanity's default
Union and it isn't with Satan
but with Adam the first Adam so Romans 5
we
read therefore just as Sin entered the
world through one man and death through
sin and in this way death came to all
people because all
sinned to be sure sin was in the world
before the law was
given but sin is not charged against
anyone's account where there is no
law ah interesting in light of what we
talked about earlier in Acts 17 but he
continues nevertheless death still
rained from the time of Adam to the time
of Moses even over those who did not sin
by breaking a command as Adam did who is
a pattern of the one to
come but the gift is not like the
trespass for if the many died by the
trespass of the one man how much more
did God's grace and the gift that came
by the grace of that one man Jesus
Christ overflow to to the
many nor can the gift of God be compared
with the result of one man's
sin the Judgment followed one sin and
brought condemnation but the gift
followed many trespasses and brought
justification for If by the trespass of
the one man death reigned through that
one man how much more will those who
receive God's abundant provision of
Grace and of the gift of righteousness
reign in life through the one man
Jesus
Christ
consequently just as one trespass
resulted in condemnation for all people
so also one righteous act resulted in
justification and life for all people
for just as through the Disobedience of
the one man the many were made Sinners
so also Through The Obedience of the one
man the many will be made
righteous thus the reading of God's holy
word so consistent in Paul's theology is
the idea of two Adams the word Adam in
Hebrew just means man there's the first
Adam and then Jesus Christ the second
Adam the new man the second
man also present in Paul's theology is
What's called
headship the idea that the male
represents his
descendants is seen all throughout the
Old
Testament and in the new such as in the
home the the the husband the male is to
lead his family in providing
protecting the priest of the home is
sort of an Antiquated phrase that used
to be used well the same is true when it
comes to all of humanity being in
Adam because Adam sinned all of his
posterity sinned in
him he was our representative before God
our federal
head we're told death then spread to all
men because all
sinned which means that all who are in
Adam in Union with him and remain in him
they will
die their only hope is to have a new
representative which is where the second
adom comes
in those who are transferred from the
first Adam into the second Adam receive
justification and tons of other
blessings
but specifically here Paul mentions
justification unlike what one receives
from the first Adam which is
death death reigned through Adam and to
all of his
posterity but life and righteousness
Reign through the second
Adam everyone that's in the first adom
is condemned by
default but all who were in the second
Adam are Made Alive Justified Sanctified
glorified Etc
they experience all of the benefits that
come from being in Union with Christ
this is all Union language it's
consistent all throughout Paul's
theology again in 1 Corinthians 15 we
were talking about this
earlier Infamous gospel chapter he
speaks about the resurrection and
eternal life and we see more headship
and Union language starting in verse 20
he says but Christ has indeed been
raised from the dead the first fruits of
those who have fallen asleep for since
death came through a man the
resurrection of the Dead comes also
through a
man for as in Adam all die so in Christ
all will be made alive but each in turn
Christ the first fruits then when he
comes those who belong to him then the
end will come when he hands over the
kingdom of God uh uh Kingdom to God the
Father after he has destroyed all
Dominion Authority and power for he must
Reign until he has put all his enemies
under his feet The Last Enemy to be
destroyed is
death thus the reading of God's holy
word so I talked about glorification
earlier and Dr Murray pointed out how
glorification is tied to the abolishment
of death in total this is what he was
alluding to death came through the uh
first Adam to all of his posterity but
Resurrection Life New Life comes through
the second adom to all of his
posterity and that's the kicker how can
you become a part of the second Adam's
posterity because you're not there by
default how can you receive all of the
benefits that come from being united to
Christ one of which is regeneration aka
the seed that Dwayne is talking about
being within you God himself dwelling
within you the answer question we're
trying to answer is how does one get
that within them
Ephesians 1 all of the highlighted text
shows all the union language in this
paropy we
read praise be to the God and father of
our Lord Jesus Christ who has blessed us
in the Heavenly Realms with every
spiritual blessing in
Christ for he chose us in him before the
creation of the world to be holy and
blameless in his sight
in love he predestined us for adoption
to sunship through Jesus Christ in
accordance with his pleasure and will to
the praise of his glorious Grace which
he has freely given us in the one he
loves in him we have Redemption through
his blood the Forgiveness of sins in
accordance with the riches of God's
grace that he lavished on us with all
wisdom and understanding he made known
to us the mystery of his will according
to his good pleasure which he purposed
in Christ to be put into effect when the
times reach their fulfillment to bring
Unity to all things in heaven and on
Earth under
Christ in him we were also chosen having
been predestined according to the plan
of him who works out everything in
Conformity with the purpose of his will
in order that we who were the first to
put our hope in Christ might be for the
praise of his
glory and you also were included in
Christ how when you heard the message of
Truth The Gospel of your
salvation when you
believed you were marked in him with a
seal the promised Holy Spirit who is a
deposit guaranteeing our inheritance
until the Redemption of those who are
God's possession to the praise of his
glory
thus the reading of God's holy
word this might be one of the plainest
and clearest didactic parts of
scripture very very
clear and if you understand and just
study Paul's theology across the
board we see numerous benefits that one
receives when they are united to the
second atom and transferred from the
kingdom of darkness into the Kingdom of
Light
we saw in verse
four the benefits of being holy and
blameless verse five we are adopted
another aspect of the OS
solutus one of the benefits Believers
receive taken from the Fallen condemned
family of Adam and adopted into the
family of
God verse seven having Redemption
through the blood of Christ the
Forgiveness of your sins
that this was a mystery in accordance
with the will of God for us to have
these benefits lavished upon us in
Christ
Jesus whom God loved you have to
understand folks the Reason God can love
a wretched sinner like you and I is
because of his love for his
son it's not because of anything in
you it's not you getting to a a
condition and a state where now now he
can really love you or now he can really
adopt you as we're going to see here in
a
moment no it's why right now I can be
seen as holy and blameless because of
being in Christ who is Holy and
blameless that's the only reason the
father loves me it's because of his love
for his son whom I'm
in verse 11 another benefit we are
chosen then at the tail end of the prapy
we're told how one can experience Union
with Christ and receive all of the in
him benefits how you can have that seed
within
you when a person hears the word of
Truth and Paul tells you what that is
there's no guessing the gospel of your
salvation and you believe that gospel
meaning when by faith you take hold of
the good news that's the instrument by
which you take hold of
this when you heard the good news about
the person and work of Jesus
what he did for you you get
what the NIV here says marked in him
with a
seal and that seal is the holy spirit
God himself who is deposited in you the
seed and that deposit is a down payment
guarantee of The Inheritance that you
will receive by virtue of being in
Christ and the purpose of all of this
isn't for God to be Vindicated from the
devil we are told what the purpose is
the very
end verse
14 which he already said previously as
well it's simply to the praise of his
glory God has chosen to create for the
purpose of glorifying himself and that
included lavishing his grace Upon A
people by loving them forever through
his son whom always desired to save and
unite them to himself through the giving
of the Holy Spirit to seal secure and
redeem them trinitarian
work father gives his son and gives a
people to the son which is what Jesus
says in John the son saves those people
accomplishing the father's will
perfectly and then the the spirit seals
them and applies the benefits that the
son procured for those individuals
to secure and redeem them for them to be
able to partake of the divine nature
what the Eastern Church for example
calls
theosis this is coming from Peter by the
way not that we ontologically become the
almighty but we share in the beatific
experience that is the Triune God
himself one receives God dwelling with
in them when they hear and believe the
gospel not through trying your best to
get to a sinlessly perfect condition
ition through Jesus giving you Grace and
power to do something that you couldn't
previously do but this is what Ellen
White taught so it's what Dwayne submits
to so let's look at how her alleged
divinely inspired teaching Compares with
what we saw in the actual inspired
writings of Romans 1 Corinthians and
Ephesians again Sons and
Daughters page 156 she writes
quote will man take hold of divine power
and with determination and perseverance
resist Satan as Christ has given him
example in his conflict with the foe in
the wilderness of Temptation God cannot
save man against his will from the power
of Satan's
artifices man must work with his human
power aided by the divine power of
Christ to resist and to conquer at any
cost to himself in short man must
overcome as Christ overcame and then
through the victory that is his
privilege to gain by the all powerful
name of Jesus he may become an heir of
God and Joint Heir with Jesus Christ
this could not be the case if Christ
Alone did all the
overcoming man must do his part he must
be Victor on his own account through the
strength and Grace that Christ gives him
man must be a coworker with Christ in
the labor of overcoming and then he will
be partaker with Christ in his glory
close
quote yeah this doesn't jive with what
we read in
scripture just like Dwayne lemon claimed
she says that God gives divine power and
Christ gives you an example of how you
can take hold of that power to overcome
Satan in your own battle with him
because Jesus in this model is the great
example there's obviously some truth to
that yes Jesus should be a role model
but what they mean by that when they
talk about the great example is you have
to attain to a perfect life that he did
through his help perfect
sinlessness and you must work with your
own power aided by divine power and
overcome as perfectly as Jesus overcame
Satan and if you're victorious in this
then you will gain the privilege of
becoming a joint Heir with
Christ yeah know Paul tells me in
Colossians I've already been seated with
Christ in the Heavenly
places because I in Christ who's already
there I've already been adopted it's not
in limbo right now because well all the
other
excuses but she says this couldn't be
the case if Jesus alone did all the
overcoming only those who overcome as
perfectly as Jesus did and arrive at a
sinlessly perfect condition will be made
a son or daughter of God that's what the
word Victory here in SD the you know
that's what the word Victory here means
in the SDA theological
vernacular achieving total sinlessness
in this life while probation is open
remember what we read earlier in the
same book on page nine no change of
character is going to take place at the
resurrection or second
coming with an imperfect character
though you won't be
saved that's what probation now is for
so in this model faith and empowers you
and then based on how well you do with
the help God gives that will determine
if you are adopted into God's family and
partake with Christ in his
glory that will determine if you're made
a son or daughter of God as the name of
the book
States yet the scriptures told us that
those who believe are already adopted by
virtue of their Union with
Christ it's in him that the born- again
believer already is a child of God
despite not yet having glorification
applied
no they're not sinlessly perfect
yet they're still seen as holy and
blameless because the father sees them
in
Christ the day is coming where the sin
will be totally abolished and and
banished out it's not just oh he just
you know like Rome tries to talk about
the legal Fiction it's not a legal
Fiction it's a legal fiction if you
don't understand what's actually being
said if you think that God just
permanently forever I'm just going to I
know that you're still a sinner but I'm
just going to declare you righteous even
though you're still just covered in sin
yeah if it ended there that would be a
valid claim of it being a legal fiction
but not when you understand
glorification is
coming and that sanctification starts in
this life and it's just distinct from
justification but Ephesians 1 tells us
that adoption is already a reality by
virtue of our Union with
Christ resur ction and glorification are
two of those benefits as
well so Ellen's idea here doesn't
comport with Paul's presentation of the
Union Believers have with Jesus and how
that is
attained yet Ephesians 1 is very simple
I mean very easy very
plain by virtue of having been
transferred from Adam to Christ by
virtue of Faith all of the benefits of
being in Christ are the Believers the
spirit is given as the seal which which
is a down payment guarantee of the
entire
inheritance some of those benefits are
already a reality like adoption and
regeneration and
justification some of those benefits are
still
future like resurrection and
glorification which is why the same Paul
can say in Romans 8 that's one of the
things that we still long for despite
his Theology and all these other places
talking about certain benefits we
already have
but the pre-earth origin narrative is in
the driver seat of Ellen White's words
and
teaching because what she is saying is
ultimately informed by the idea that God
and the Ten Commandments are on trial
and Satan is making the accusation that
you can't keep them so Jesus came to
silence that accusation and show you
that a fallen man can keep the law and
that it's immutable so if you want to
enter Heaven you'll have to achieve what
Jesus did in his Earthly life life and
get to as sinless of a condition as him
I show this all the
time this is precisely what she says in
great controversy while the
investigative judgment is going on
that's when probation is open but once
it ends the time of trouble will start
and if you haven't gotten to a character
condition completely identical to Jesus
you won't make it Satan's accusations
against you will stand Jesus will have
ceased being a mediator and you will be
lost and notice the word
Victory like I said earlier that is a
buzzword in this system for sinless
perfectionism total victory over sin
such that you sin no more in any way
shape form or
fashion because notice not even a sinful
thought cross Christ's
mind that's the condition you must
achieve before probation closes not even
a sinful thought
and these aren't one-offs folks so let's
not hear this out of context excuse I've
read thousands of pages of Ellen White I
get so sick of hearing this like do you
guys not think that I actually go and
read what I pull quotes from that
doesn't mean that I'm perfect my point
is is I'm not quote
mining I know this system very
well this isn't out of context I could
show you hundreds of quotes of her
saying
this Desire of Ages page 763 again
another one of these barricaded by a
thus sayith the Lord like we saw in the
quote
earlier quote the Warfare against God's
law which was begun in heaven will be
continued until the end of
time every man will be tested obedience
or disobedience is the question to be
decided by the whole world all will be
called to choose between the law of God
and the laws of men here the dividing
line will be drawn there will be but two
classes every character will be fully
developed and all will show whether they
have chosen the side of loyalty or that
of
rebellion close
quote so if you don't achieve total
sinlessness perfectly developed
character identical to that of of Jesus
you demonstrate that you've actually
chosen to side with Satan in the great
controversy same stuff we saw earlier
and I've shown quotes on this the review
and Herald December 10
1890 article where they say trying your
best isn't good enough you're just a
hobbling along after God claiming to
follow him but you're a a moral
and that's not good enough that the
character of the Saints is defined by
those who truly do have total Victory
just like Dwayne is talking
about and for those unaware another part
of the reason this plays a larger role
in the system is not only because you
have to vindicate at God by
demonstrating that his law can be kept
perfectly by a fallen human but it's
also to demonstrate that you're safe to
save and be trusted to uh be let into
heaven
quote the law of God is the standard by
which characters to be measured and he
whose life is in harmony with that law
is worthy to be trusted but of what
value is the testimony of a man whose
life and teaching contradict the law of
Jehovah he then measures himself by his
own finite standard and make claim for
himself as much as does the pope of Rome
but in the light of the detector of sin
his character may be wholly wanting
close
quote so the Adventist God needs to see
that you won't let sin enter into heaven
again like Satan did so that's part of
what probation is for
too you have to show an omniscient being
that you can keep the
rules the standard by which this perfect
character that you must develop will be
measured is The Ten Commandments
again not a one-off she writes
quote a second probation purchased by
the death of the Son of God has been
granted to the human race those who do
not respect the sacrifice enough to obey
the law which in dying Christ magnified
can never enter the city of
God on Earth they form habits of
Disobedience and rebellion and if
permitted to enter Heaven they would
carry with them a spirit that would
bring about a second
Rebellion close quote
yeah more evidence that Ellen White did
not understand
glorification and saw it simply as a
transformation of the physical body to
be made
Immortal nothing
else she says Jesus came to secure for
mankind a second probation like Adam and
Eve were on and on this probationary
period you need to get to a sinlessly
perfect character or you won't be
trusted to be let into heaven since you
would bring with you a spirit of
rebellion
and letting sin enter Heaven Again would
then lead to a second great controversy
starting yeah except this flies in the
face of Hebrews 12 which compares the
mount Heavenly Mount Zion with SI that
terrifying scene that occurred at siai
where the entire Mountain shakes
according to Exodus and the author of
Hebrews uses that as a picture to
compare and contrast with the Heavenly
Mountain the better one that the New
Covenant believer is ushered up to and
he tells us this better Mountain cannot
be
shaken well halt what does he mean by
shaken not too long ago we saw Mark
Finley tried to use this text to support
the SDA doctrine of the
shaking where he just did word concept
fallacy and then imported into the word
shaking the avist idea of the sifting
and the shaking wow but the author's
point is that man's sin res resulted in
that terrifying scene at SI that was the
barrier between God and
man their sin had separated them from
God they couldn't touch the mountain
lest any of them die including
animals but through the gospel the
person and work of
Jesus Hebrews tells us that we can
approach a better mountain with a better
mediator than
Moses and a better priest than the
Levites
and we can enter before God into his
presence with
boldness because of our identity in
Christ Union with Christ he opened a New
and Living Way for us through his blood
Hebrews
10 he says that back in in in chapter
nine he says that while the Earthly
Ministry was going on talking about the
Levites the way into the presence of God
was closed off to everyone except the
priest and only one one day a
year but then he gets to chapter 10
where he talks about how Christ is
better than all of that and he says
through the blood of Christ Hebrews
10:19 through
21 through the blood of Christ a New and
Living Way has been open for us to be
able to enter into the presence of God
all of us not just once a
year this is all tied to Union with
Christ but the point being in Hebrews 12
is that the Heavenly Mount Zion cannot
be shaken by sin because he explains
that through what Christ accomplished he
removed that which can be
shaken it will not be possible for sin
to enter into the Heavenly Mount
Zion which is also evidence that the SDA
church is teaching that heaven is a
return to the Garden of Eden is flawed
where we're headed is better than Eden
can't be shaken but God doesn't need to
see if you can be trusted in heaven once
one re receives glorification all sinful
propensities Temptations desires Etc
completely
gone
but this is same stuff we saw from Ellen
White is even found in the SDA Bible
commentary folks because it's the Ellen
White SDA Bible commentary quote Satan
will work his miracles to deceive he
will set up his power as Supreme the
church may appear as about to fall but
it does not fall it remains while the
sinners and Zion will be sifted out the
chaff separated from the precious wheat
this is a terrible ordeal but
nevertheless it must take place none but
those who have been Overcoming By the
blood of the lamb and the word of their
testimony will be found with the loyal
and true without spot or stain of sin
without Gile in their
mouths The Remnant that purify their
souls by obeying the truth gather
strength from the trying process
exhibiting the beauty of holiness
amid the surrounding apostasy close
quote so they're speaking here about the
sifting and the shaking within the
remnant church that as times become more
and more difficult more and more sdas
are going to be shaken out of the
movement it's going to be too difficult
you know I hear this all the time from
sdas they love this excuse when anyone
leaves ah yeah see you just weren't in
for the it's hard I know but you just
reren in for this you know achieving
total
sinlessness yeah totally diluted while
they're literally just steeped in
sin but the shaking and the sifting was
supposedly prophetically told for
told like I said Adventist the the super
duper holy ones like Dwayne lemon who
glow in the dark they'll be overcoming
sin in total by the blood of Jesus and
they'll be loyal and true without spot
or stain of sin upon them they will have
purified their souls by obeying the law
which will exhibit beauty of Holiness to
those around them
everything in this model pertaining to
security Union perseverance Etc it's
always inward
facing what do I mean by that it's all
about looking to yourself if you're
doing
enough I know a lot of Adventists are
going to say adventism we we're
christocentric it's all about Jesus yeah
that sounds nice friend that that sounds
nice
just Christian buzzword bloviation
no this model constantly is it's
anthropocentric it's constantly looking
at you Jesus has done all he can do are
you doing your part are you doing enough
get busy get busy get busy which is why
so many honest Adventists live in
constant anxiety and worry and fear
because they'll get Knuckleheads like
this guy beating them over the head with
the law all the time telling them if
you're not totally sinless that you
don't have God dwelling in you so you
need to try harder and get all the sin
out of your life and yeah friend I'm
going to tell you and there are people
you can talk to that are a lot more
mature in the faith than I am who will
tell you the same thing the longer it
goes the more broken you become over it
because it's almost like your awareness
to the depth of your sin is just
highlighted more and more and more and
the prayer becomes harder and harder and
harder God please free me from this body
of death I long for that day
this movement man it is always always
always a man- centered disposition where
they turn your eyes inward instead of
outside of yourself to Jesus which is
where salvation comes from this is why
the sacraments are so
important that's where a person receives
Jesus it's where they receive salvation
because Jesus is salvation and he comes
from outside of
us where we fix our eyes on him and his
righteousness that come apart from the
law Romans
3:21 again believing the gospel is how
one receives the seed of God indwelling
them not through attempting to clean up
your life that absolutely happens do not
get me wrong I'm talking about the
correlation the
causation that absolutely happens as God
chastises Those whom he loves and adopts
into his family again regeneration is a
part of all of this but it happens
because you're in his family and he
loves you not that he's waiting to see
how perfect you become with his help to
then call you a son or daughter and a
joint Heir with Christ no they do not
understand Union with
Christ we could get into John 15 where
they talk about abiding in Christ that's
the phrase that they'll often use where
it's this like it's talked about as if
it's this like Moment by moment thing
because it's all in light of the great
controversy the like Angel on one
shoulder and the devil on the other and
they're just like pulling you back and
forth every moment and every possible
moment you could possibly not be abiding
in Christ so every day it's just every
moment am I abiding in Christ it just is
crazy man it's totally ridiculous it
constantly has you distracted on
yourself I truly hurt folks for Seventh
Day
Adventist I I remember growing up in
this gospel desert where it is just
constant brow beating I don't care what
pocket you're in
there's no law gospel distinction
regardless of where you're at I don't
care if you're a California Adventist or
a Jamaica
Adventist it's all personal piety that
if you read the Bible more you do more
good works you pray more you do do do do
do that will eventually result in God
being pleased with
you or you'll get the Neo
Adventist we're going to be doing a
video on that soon uh yeah yeah we'll
get into their understand understanding
of Union with Christ and how they Tred
to do this like they always do this
Evangelical hybridized thing where they
say a bunch of good stuff it's like okay
you're not even preaching
adventism you're literally just talking
about a bunch of Evangelical Christian e
oh and then they get to talking about
the great controversy theme ah there we
go there we
go but like Ellen also taught the only
way to obtain God's favor is through the
Ten
Commandments that's testimonies for the
Church volume 4 Page uh 27 27 okay for
those that want to go fact chick me no
the only way for you to obtain God's
favor is to believe the
gospel the true gospel to be in
Christ because Christ The Father loves
those whom are in his
son not not the cursed false SDA gospel
which is only going to bring you death
and despair and
anxiety Union with Christ happens when
one
believes the gospel and they're given
the Holy Spirit as a seal not the
Sabbath not the Sabbath
man the Sabbath is not the down payment
guarantee of our
inheritance the Seal of God is tied to
God's promise to
us of all the benefits we receive by
being in Union with Christ the
son My Hope Is that many seventh day
Adventists would come to know this
truth flee from this deceptive movement
that is going to drag your soul to
predition that they'd come to find
newness of Life In
Christ and experience what true freedom
in Christ is like how liberating it is
to serve God for an entirely different
reason than what we're hearing put for
fourth by Dwayne
lemon next clip is a little long but we
need to hear the whole thing pay very
close attention
here let's
continue again when we look at that
serpent we often we we try not to do it
during the session so do you mind if we
do it afterwards okay thanks so much so
again when we look at this idea I
thought the Serpent's head was crushed
at the cross and if not then will when
will it be crushed because this is the
question that people want to know is
when when will the Serpent's head be
crushed because Jesus definitely died on
the cross but at the cross was the
Serpent's head crushed and was he
destroyed what do you
think well let me tell you this if he
was
destroyed well then why do we have so
many
problems the only reason we still have
these problems is because Satan still
exists you understand that so Satan is
not destroyed yet so then we need to
understand well then what did happen at
the cross because that's a that's a
legit question that people ask is I
thought the Serpent's head was crushed
at the cross now if it's not crushed at
the cross then the question is then when
will it be crushed so let's let's
entertain that question real
quick at
Calvary the most Monumental event took
place Jesus died the death we were
supposed to die die and offers to you
and I according to his grace and love
the life that he was supposed to live he
literally made a trade-off he says I'll
take your death and I'll give you my
life now you got to remember God is
eternal is that right God is eternal so
when Jesus said I'll take your death he
was saying I'm going to take on as it
were the the the punishment that all
Sinners would would suffer that's why he
said my God my God why have you for Aken
me he was sensing what all guilty
Sinners are going to suffer God turning
his face from you remember we read that
so Jesus took that on but Jesus in his
very nature he is God Eternal so when he
takes on our death and gives us his life
he's not just giving us a few more
decades he's giving to us eternal life
what a wonderful gift the wages of sin
is death but the gift of God is eternal
life through Jesus Christ Our Lord now
watch this
because of this beautiful tradeoff the
question is well then what happened at
Calvary what happened let's take a look
at it the Bible says in Hebrews 2 for as
much then as the children are partakers
of Flesh and Blood he also himself
likewise took part of the same that
through death he might destroy him that
had the power of death that is the devil
the cross
ensures the destru destuction of Satan
it ensures it but it didn't happen at
the cross are you following that that
that power that Satan had over us was
now broken because of the Cal because of
Calvary but Satan wasn't destroyed yet
so let's talk about this a little
bit what is it going to take for God
what is it going to take for God to
ultimately Crush completely Satan's head
in the way that I teach it
at the cross the crushing process
began listen carefully to what I'm
saying at the cross the crushing of
Satan's head the crushing process
began but it's evident even in 2024 that
his head is not yet completely crushed
because he's still wreaking havoc in the
lives of people
today so then the question is what's it
going to take for him to have his head
completely crushed so that the prophecy
reaches its ultimate fulfillment let's
take a
look Okay so we've got to do some
theological triage here this was a
perfect example of how Dwayne does not
understand the difference between
Redemption
accomplished and Redemption
applied if you have been here through
the whole session I hope you are seeing
this so the question and
focus when was the head of the serpent
in Genesis 3:15
crushed Dwayne and great controversy
theology say it wasn't at the cross
because Satan wasn't destroyed there and
by
destroyed they mean blotted from
existence and since we still see
problems in the world well that couldn't
have been where the head of the serpent
was crushed he then appealed to Hebrews
2 to support his claim which says that
through death Jesus would destroy the
one who has the power of death namely
the devil and he said the death of
Christ at the cross only
assures the crushing of the Serpent's
head but it wasn't where such took place
and in his
words he said the way he teaches it is
that at the cross the crushing
process began
got
that but is that what the Serpent's head
being crushed in Genesis 3:15
means that the crushing of his head is
the equivalent of him being totally
destroyed out of
existence is that what Hebrews 2 is
saying that the devil being crushed only
happens at the point of him being cast
into
hell this is like I pointed out earlier
regarding what SDA you know what you'll
hear from them regarding sin being put
away at the
cross that if that's what Hebrews 9:26
says how can that be the case if we
still see sin in the world well here you
see another error in thinking that is
produced by not understanding Redemption
accomplished versus Redemption applied
so let's work through this because
Dwayne is not exegeting the Bible here
he is simply bringing the great
controversy theology to the Bible and
then periodically citing proof texts
along with assertions he he's not
walking through the text verse by verse
he's appealing to
verses taking them out of of wherever
they're
at removing them from what the author
may be seeking to convey and is trying
to make application before doing that
process again I thought they were
supposed to only affirm the historical
grammatical method of Bible
interpretation I I can't find the
Adventist leader anywhere that does this
first let's look at where he's getting
this from ultimately to then bring it to
the Bible then we will look at scripture
contextually and see how this comports
so the great controversy
claims what Dwayne is getting at
regarding the crushing process beginning
is ultimately reiterating the seven-step
sanctuary model I talked about this in
part three of the series I did with the
guys over at cultish for those that saw
it you will recall that they see the
altar of sacrifice in the Old Testament
Priestly
system the altar of sacrifice as a
picture of the Cross of Christ no harm
no foul there
sure but they try and draw out of seven
aspects of the sanctuary service seven
different steps that lay out in order
that pointed to seven steps that Jesus
would antitypical
follow so it started in Step One by him
coming to our camp aka the world so the
Israelites had their camp and then the
Tabernacle was set up in the
camp that's supposed to be be step
one so they had a camp set up a
tabernacle Christ as the Tabernacle
comes to our camp step one the second
step involved the priests working in the
outer Court which is where the altar of
sacrifice
was but before Jesus could complete this
second step he had to develop a perfect
character by weaving together a perfect
robe of righteousness as a
man with that completed after 30 years
then he began his Earthly Ministry in
the outer Court of the sanctuary where
the altar of burnt offering and the
labor were
located after living a perfect life the
father placed the sins of the world upon
him at Calvary causing him to experience
the agony of the second death that
Sinners
deserve and this is regarded as the
foundational act and starting point in
the process of
Salvation it's where the atoning
sacrifice took place but not where
atonement was accomplished it was only
the start of that process that's what
Dwayne is getting
at you remember earlier he
mentioned sin the sanctuary and
prophecy that's what he's getting at
with the sanctuary but no where does
Scripture tell us that the seven as
these seven aspects of the Old Testament
Sanctuary service are seven typological
steps of what Jesus would
chronologically follow in dealing with
the sin
problem they have theorized this with
the help of Ellen White's visions and
then declare it dogmatically but you're
not going to find scripture telling you
to interpret it this
way Satan was crushed at the cross and
the fact that Dwayne cited Hebrews 2 to
try and say that he wasn't and the
crushing process only began is rather
ironic but let's start working through
this
okay first is Genesis 3:15 talking about
Satan being utterly
destroyed or is it talking about when
the victory of Christ over Satan's sin
and death would be
accomplished that's the fundamental fork
in the road
notice something Dwayne didn't focus on
that causes his claim to backfire
badly for starters Genesis 3:15 doesn't
communicate that the action and focus
will be a process but even if it
did let's grant that it is conveying
that in order for this to be the
case the bruising of Jesus's
heel also would need to be a process
because the two are correlated what does
the crushing of the Serpent's head
result
in he will crush your head and you will
strike his
heel some translation some translations
will say and bruise his
heel so my
question is Jesus progressively being
crushed bruised whatever term you want
to use
and did the process of that bruising
begin at Calvary where it's still going
on at this
time because if we can establish from
the
scriptures that the bruising or striking
of Jesus
involved and it isn't or or what all it
involved when it took place and that
it's not going on currently then the
crushing of the Serpent's head also
can't be a progressive drawn out
process which great controversy theology
by way of the sanctuary model has to
have be the case so let's be cursed
according to Dwayne and consult some
Hebrew grammarians who can assist us in
uh understanding what the grammar of the
word bruising in this text is
saying by Hebrew grammarians folks I
mean
Isaiah Isaiah 53 tells us when Jesus was
bruised Messianic prophecy about Christ
we read in part he was despised and
rejected by mankind a man of suffering
and familiar with
pain like one from whom people hide
their faces he was despised and we held
him in low
esteem surely he took up our pain and
bore our
suffering yet we considered him punished
by God stricken by him and
Afflicted but he was pierced for our
trans agressions he was crushed for our
iniquities the punishment that brought
us peace was on him and by his wounds we
are healed thus the reading of God's
holy word so when was Christ
bruised When sin was placed on him at
Calvary when verse 10 of this chapter
says it pleased the Lord to crush him
and he
suffered this would mean that Jesus
isn't Progressive ly being
bruised and even the sanctuary model
agrees because Jesus is supposedly on
step five and the altar of sacrifice was
step
two so even they recognize that Jesus
isn't suffering
anymore but that's one let's really dig
on this
further now the Lord Jesus's own
teaching about his death and what that
work would
accomplish the context of John is on
precisely
that and within the flow of Jesus's own
explanation we get more insight into
answering our question little bit of a
read here John 1220 through 31 we read
now there were some Greeks among those
who went up to worship at the
festival they these Greeks came to
Phillip who was from Betha in Galilee
with a request sir they said we would
like to see Jesus
Philip went to tell Andrew Andrew and
Philip in turn told
Jesus Jesus replied the hour has come
for the son of man to be
glorified very truly I tell you unless a
kernel of wheat falls to the ground and
dies it remains only a Single
Seed oh but if it dies it produces many
seeds and anyone who loves their life
will lose it while anyone who hates
their life in this world will keep it
for eternal life whoever serves me must
follow me and where I am my servant also
will be my father will honor the one who
serves me now my soul is troubled and
what shall I say father save me from
this hour no it was for this very reason
I came to this hour father glorify your
name then a voice Came From Heaven I
have have glorified it and will glorify
it
again the crowd that was there and heard
it said it had thundered others said an
angel had spoken to
him Jesus said this voice was for your
benefit not mine now is the time for
judgment on this world now the prince of
this world will be driven out and I when
I lifted up from the earth will draw all
people to myself he said this to show
the kind of death he was going to
die thus the reading of God's holy word
all right so catch
this there were Gentiles among those who
went to worship and these Greeks came up
to philli and asked to see Jesus Philip
and Andrew then go and relay this
information to Jesus and what is his
reply the hour has come for him to be
glorified but before this can occur
he explains that unless a kernel of
wheat falls into the ground and dies it
only remains a
seed so think about that if you never if
it never gets
buried
gone it's wasted it just nothing comes
of
it but if it dies and is
buried it rises in growth to eventually
produce many
seeds this is him obviously using an
analogy for his soon death that must
occur before his glorification could
take
place and like we saw Paul used the same
imagery in 1 Corinthians 15
earlier we're going to look at more of
that chapter in a moment but he then
rhetorically asks now my soul is
troubled and should uh uh uh and should
he say my father you know should he
should I say my father save me from this
hour to which he answers his own inquiry
by saying not at all because this is the
exact thing he came
for that's what Genesis 3:15
promised that the Messiah would
come crush the Serpent's head and it
would bruise his heel but he'd be
victorious despite this being the case
but in light of this fact Jesus says to
the father to glorify his name in his
death to which the father actually
responds audibly and says I have
glorified it and will glorify it again
to which the entire Place Thunders and
people that were present thought it was
an
angel Jesus then responds to this where
he tells them that the voice from heaven
was for their own benefit not his and
then we get the kicker verse
31 now is the time for judgment on this
world now the prince of this world Satan
himself will be driven out and when
Christ is lifted up he'll draw the world
to himself and all of this he said to
show the kind of death he would die
meaning he would be lifted up on a Roman
cross like the serpent on the pole with
Moses
pictured so make the connection
according to
Christ through his death the prince of
this world would be driven
out and after that work was accomplished
Jesus would be glorified
is Jesus being bruised in his glorified
state of course not which is why looking
at 1 Corinthians 15 again in conjunction
with this is vital just a different part
of the
chapter earlier in the chapter we see
Paul talking about death and
resurrection and this same analogy from
the Lord Jesus is used again here to
refer to the lowly body that we possess
being swn into the ground to then be
raised a glorified body and Jesus is the
example that Paul uses to say the same
will happen to those United to Christ
resurrection and glorification are two
of the benefits that those of us in
Christ have yet to receive but the
spirit that indwells us is a down
payment guarantee that we will receive
them both so he states in the in the
verses leading up to that to this that
if Christ is not raised from the dead
our faith is in vain and we're the most
you know to be pied our faith absolutely
hinges upon the Resurrection being true
to which he says but of course Christ
was raised from the dead the first
fruits of the Resurrection little tie
there to the Old Testament Feast of
first fruits but the first Hut in a
wrapping on Preparation
day which is what we call Friday and
they remained there through the Sabbath
to then be unwrapped and presented to
God the father on the day after the
Sabbath the eth or first
day well this is what Jesus as the true
first fruits did he was wrapped and
buried on Preparation day remained in
that wrapping until the first day where
he walked out of the Tomb to present
himself before the
Father which Romans 1 tells us was the
proof itself that his sacrifice was
accepted otherwise he wouldn't have
walked out of the Tomb he would have
proven to be just another sinner like
everyone else who dies and remains there
but then he writes this about the
resurrection of the Dead
but someone will ask how are the dead
raised with what kind of body will they
come how foolish what you sew does not
come to life unless it dies when you
seow you do not plant the body that will
die or or that will be but just a seed
perhaps of wheat or of something
else but God gives it a body as he has
determined and to each kind of seed he
gives its own body not all flesh is the
same people have one kind of Flesh
animals have another Birds another and
fish another there are also heavenly
bodies and there are Earthly bodies but
the Splendor of the heavenly bodies is
one kind and the Splendor of the Earthly
bodies is another the sun has one kind
of Splendor the Moon another and the
Stars another and the star differs from
star in splendor so will it be with the
resurrection of the Dead the body that
is sown is par perishable it is raised
imperishable it is sown in dishonor it
is raised in glory it is sown in
weakness it is raised in power it is
sown a natural body it is raised a
spiritual
body if there is a natural
body oh sorry
folks I have it cut off here he says if
there is a natural body there's also a
spiritual body so so it is written the
first man Adam became a life or a living
being the last Adam a lifegiving
spirit the spiritual did not come first
but the natural and after that the
spiritual the first man was of the Dust
of the earth thus second man is of
Heaven as was the Earthly man so are
those who are of the earth and as is The
Heavenly Man so also are those who are
of
heaven and just just as we have borne
the image of the Earthly man so shall we
bear the image of The Heavenly Man so
quickly here this is perfectly
consistent with what Jesus said in John
12 what is sown in death is then raised
in Resurrection we see the same parallel
of the first Adam and the second Adam
like we looked at
earlier but in light of this information
Paul
continues I declare to you brothers and
sisters that flesh and blood cannot
inherit the kingdom of God nor does the
perishable inherit the imperishable
listen I tell you a mystery we will not
all sleep but we will all be changed in
a flash in the twinkling of an eye at
the last trumpet for the trumpet will
sound the dead will be raised
imperishable and we will be
changed for the perishable must clothe
itself with the imperishable and the
Mortal with
immortality when the perishable has been
clothed with the imperishable and the
Mortal with immortality then the saying
that is written will come
true death has been swallowed up in
Victory where o death is your Victory
where o death is your Sting the sting of
death is sin and the power of sin is the
law but thanks be to God he gives us the
victory through our Lord Jesus Christ
thus the reading of God's holy
word so what is
sown to then be raised will be
transformed in the twinkling of an eye
that's glorification being
apped and we will have physical bodies
like the Lord Jesus's resurrected
glorified body the perishable will be
clothed with the
imperishable and we even see Paul
recognizing the distinction between when
Redemption was accomplished in full
versus when he recognized it being
applied in full he already told us
earlier that if Christ was not raised
from the dead our faith is in vain
that's the accomplishment point of
redemption but we see him continue by
saying in Verses
54-56 that when glorification is applied
then the saying that was written death
where is your Victory oh death where is
your sting that will come
true in other words just like we saw him
say back in verses 24-
26 for Christ must Reign until he's put
all his enemies under his feet and The
Last Enemy to be destroyed is
death so how can both of these things be
true without Paul contradicting
himself he said death was already
overcome by the means of Christ's
Resurrection which is why our faith is
not in
vain but at the same time he says death
has yet to be
destroyed is Paul contradicting
himself no of course not Paul didn't
conflate Jesus's accomplishing of
redemption in full with the full
application of what Christ
accomplished at this at a at a previous
point the bonds of death have been
broken
entirely death has been defeated it
couldn't hold him it couldn't contain
him which is why it can't contain those
who are united to him either his
resurrection was our resurrection and in
the future the actual abolition of death
will occur where where it along with the
contents of Hades will be cast into into
the Lake of Fire according to revelation
2014 and
15 but back to the previous slide also
notice the victory language of
Paul piggybacking off of death having
lost its sting over the believer he says
the sting of death is sin and the power
of sin is the law but thanks be to God
who gives us the victory through our
Lord Jesus
Christ the phrase through Christ in
Paul's theology is also a term of
Union the same Paul that wrote this
wrote Romans 5
since death has no hold on Christ it has
no hold on those who are in him that's
how you have total victory over sin and
it
sting Romans 8 there's therefore now no
condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus this compared to what we saw
earlier from Ellen White where through
Christ would be understood as some
empowerment phrase an enabling
concept now that's not consistent with
Paul's own theology death is already
overcome for the
believer God has promised me an
inheritance by means of giving himself
to
me but a more pointed question why is
what Paul says here about glorification
important to the question of Jesus being
bruised don't forget that was the
question you might be thinking this
seems like a long way to get stick with
me Jesus said in John 12 that the hour
had come for him to be
glorified but first he would need to be
sewn into the ground like a seed to then
be raised and that's exactly what Paul
says will happen to us as well Jesus
isn't suffering in his glorified
State he's already had glorification
applied to his human body as the first
fruits of the new
creation which
means that the bruising of his heel
cannot be a progressive process over
time and neither can the crushing of
Satan's
head this is entirely consistent with
what uh uh entirely
inconsistent with the way Dwayne read
Hebrews to but Twisted
it that text is entirely consistent with
consistent with everything we've seen
from Paul and
Jesus Hebrews 21:14 does not say that
the
process of the Serpent's head being
crushed would begin at Jesus's
death it speaks
objectively I'm not saying it has to
verbatim say the process began and well
look because it doesn't verbatim say it
no I'm not using verbatim
fallacy it what it objectively says
proves it's not talking about a process
that through death Jesus objectively
broke the bonds of death which is why it
has no more sting for those in
Christ while Christ's victory was
secured at the
cross its final consummation will occur
at his second coming when Satan is ult
ultimately thrown into the Lake of Fire
Revelation 20110 so folks the bruising
of the heel of Jesus was his passion his
suffering on the cross and his death but
the crushing of the head is referring to
his ultimate victory over
Satan sin and death
and this occurred in his
resurrection where death was conquered
that's the
gospel that's why when I'm listening to
this from him in preparation for this
I'm like
dude so many
opportunities to to highlight the
glories and just always comes back to
you you you yeah Jesus made something
possible and he's great and yeah we're
Christ Centric but it's all about you
are you doing enough is the seed in
you the law like a mirror just
constantly making you feel like
garbage yet the Glorious good news is
the gospel to that bad
news good news about the person work of
Christ who he is God in
flesh the second person of the Triune
God what he accomplished in his work his
perfectly sinless Life Death burial and
resurrection that was what accomplished
Redemption and full and crushed
Satan Genesis 3:15 is not talking about
when Satan will be cast into the Lake of
Fire but since Dwayne lemon and great
controversy theology do not understand
the distinction between Redemption being
accomplished in full versus when it will
be applied in full they arrive at faulty
conclusions Satan's already been
defeated he was crushed the strong man
has been bound and cast out Matthew
12:29 Satan has been sentenced in the
accomplishment of redemption he will be
executed in the final application of
redemption this doesn't mean that the
crushing of Satan's head is a
progressive progress over a long per you
know drawn out period of time but SDA
theology needs this to be the case for
their entire Sanctuary Theory to be
correct but Genesis 3:15 cannot be
referring to Satan's head progressively
being crushed by the Messiah without
also claiming that Jesus is being
bruised
progressively which began in his death
on the cross and is still going on
today because the two are
correlated the bruising was for telling
of his passion on the cross upon
resurrecting the final blow was made to
Satan and the resurrected Christ walked
out of the Tomb in his glorified
body there's no suffering in the
glorified state which proves Jesus is
not currently being bruised so he can't
currently be crushing the Serpent's head
in a process that began 2,000 years ago
Genesis 3:15 is talking about the Life
Death burial and resurrection of Our
Lord which is what did the crushing and
bruising in full and that drives a death
blow you want to talk about crushing to
the avenus sanctuary Theory no pun
intended so in
closing avenus theology is the big
problem Dwayne opened up by talking
about the big problem that God has no
adventism is the big
problem the god of the Bible is not on
trial by his own creatures
folks Psalm 711 God is a righteous
judge that that statement
alone gives a just a a striking blow to
the SDA
edifice because God cannot
lie and God has
spoken God has spoken in his word that
he's righte that he's the Divine
judge judged by no
mortal any system that causes one to
think in Reverse is not of divine origin
Ellen White was absolutely right in
Patriarchs and Prophets that whatever
contradicts God's word we can be sure
proceeds from
Satan and this great controversy mind
virus that she claims came from God
violating the third commandment to not
bear his name
falsely is an anti-biblical false
demonic anti-gospel
message and if you truly believe that
which I do
that it's a demonic message Adventists
need
warned and this sort of analyzing needs
to be done and out
there any system folks that that tells
you God is on trial and you're in the
judge's
seat you're the one creatures of any
kind they're the ones that get to
determine who God is and who no
no it's not Up For Debate it's not up
for
exam you have a creature Creator
distinction issue going on
there I I hope you all are able to see
how great controversy ideology is in the
driver's seat with this movement doesn't
matter where they appeal to in the
Bible they have a starting
presupposition that their Paradigm is
correct that Paradigm comes from Ellen
White's pre-earth origin narrative not
scripture the Paradigm then colors the
line of Any Given passage of the Bible
where they don't walk through a text and
derive out of it what the author is
saying but instead they will read proof
texts here and there here a little there
a little followed by making
assertions at least as it pertains to
trying to prove great controversy
theology from the text of
scripture but it doesn't pass the sniff
test God expects us as His Image bearers
to use our higher critical iCal
faculties including our god-given reason
Adventist
please use your
reason and when we stop to analyze many
of these claims it's clear that the
system doesn't properly understand
various foundational aspects of theology
such as glorification Union with Christ
Redemption accomplished versus
Redemption applied and numerous other
things and all of this is because they
have a false gospel
you can tell yourself all you want well
my pastor this my pastor that you can
make all the excuses in the book friend
but that in and of itself is enough that
should cause you to go e I'm out false
gospel Galatians 1 anyone preaching a
false gospel is under a curse from God
you need to make
sure when there's language like that
there's no stronger language that Paul
could use in the the Hebrew or in the
the Greek
language it's not some side is you it's
not me making a gripe about nothing I
can't tell you how many Adventists now
former
Adventists I'm walking with who hated my
guts at first yeah hate me all you want
throw the tomatoes you can hate me tell
a cows come
home they're not in that position
anymore because they listened they
understood and now they're saying ah I
understand why now
ah Adventist Church has a false
gospel it's not the it's not a movement
that's built
on the foundation of the Apostles and
the prophets who received their
Foundation laying ability from Jesus
himself and unlike in Dwayne's abuse of
Jeremiah 175 to try and say you'll be
cursed by God for Consulting others
about scripture Galatians 1 outright
says anyone preaching a false gospel is
cursed by God and that's not being taken
out of
context which seventh day adventism is
like I showed one of many they have
their own version of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ I've been saying this for years
and I appreciate Dr Pauline unashamedly
putting that out there for us if you're
an Adventist heed this warning from Paul
and get out of this organization which
is Under The Curse Of God come be a
Christian contact us at answering
adventism
docomond by and his vicarious death on
the cross for Sinners until next time
God bless
[Music]